Easy. I-I-I-Easy.
Poggers.
Auf geht's.
Massive.
Massive Pog.
Muss jetzt mal checken, ob Twitch es wieder kapiert hat,
dass die Auflösung höher ist, äh, nicht die Auflösung, stimmt nicht, ja die Bitrate höher ist.
Auflösung ist ja wie immer.
Bitrate. Moment. Werbung.
Okay, Easy Money, Easy Life.
Eigentlich, warum, sag mal, eigentlich bin ich dumm.
Warum mache ich nicht einfach mal ein Stream selbst 20.000 mal auf und gucke mir Werbung an?
Easy Money.
Okay, das wäre, glaube ich, Viewporting, das darf man nicht, ja.
Ich glaube, das fällt da bestimmt drunter.
Richtig, Five-Hand-Time.
Ach, Far Cry 6, ist das raus?
Ist das schon am Start?
Taugt das?
Jemand eine Ahnung? Taugt Far Cry 6?
Also ich persönlich fand Far Cry 3, Poggers.
Far Cry 4 fand ich auch noch ziemlich gut.
Die anderen habe ich nicht mehr gespielt. Seit gestern, ja.
Taugt das was?
Lohnt sich, das gibt so viele Spiele gerade aktuell,
die man spielen muss.
More of the Scare.
Das fände ich nicht schlimm, wenn das drumherum okay ist.
Hätte ich keine Probleme mit.
Na, gleiche wie immer muss man sagen, es hat sich ja verschlimmbessert.
Hat sich ja verschlimmbessert.
Es hat mir auch überhaupt nicht mehr zugesagt, der fünfte Teil.
Also der fünfte Teil, Far Cry, hat mir überhaupt nicht zugesagt.
Der dritte war geil, der vierte auch.
Der fünfte hat mir nicht zugesagt.
Und was mir überhaupt nicht zugesagt, das war das letzte,
dieser Spin-Off vom fünften.
Das hat mich total abgeschreckt irgendwie.
Und ich dachte eigentlich vom Setting her und so,
das könnte wieder cool werden, das Sechser.
Das Far Cry 6 könnte wieder richtig Pock werden.
Was, man hat jetzt einen Krokodil als Pet.
Ich weiß, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der an Schnipp, Schnapp, Schnappi denken muss.
So was vor 15 Jahren oder so mal, kennt das noch jemand?
So eine Cringe-Geschichte.
Nicht dieses Lieder, okay, du erinnerst dich noch daran.
Ach, Primal gab es ja auch noch.
Nee, Primal habe ich auch nicht gespielt.
Ich habe Far Cry 3 gespielt und Far Cry 4 und das fand ich beides nice.
Genau, danach kam Primal.
Primal hat mich überhaupt nicht angesprochen.
Und dann habe ich die Reihe so ein bisschen aus den Augen fallen
und dann haben sie das Fünfer angekündigt.
Und das Fünfer hat mich auch nicht angesprochen.
Das Game ist selbst in 720p zu low für TimePC.
Was hast du denn?
Übrigens, by the way, Leute, ich mache das übrigens immer noch fertig,
dass sie denken, ich bin da Friseur, aber okay.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, ich habe ein Video gemacht.
Heute noch mal hochgeladen zu Battlefield 2042.
Und da habe ich mal die ganzen Probleme, die wir auch gestern schon im Stream
ausreichend heftig diskutiert haben, noch mal reingepackt.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich die Emotes?
Die sind richtig gut geworden, oder?
Du bist hier nicht am Dauersuchten, das gibt doch in dem Game nichts.
Was willst du denn hier Dauersuchten?
Es gibt eine Map, fünf Waffen oder so und sonst nichts.
Gibt ja nichts.
Hat ja auch überhaupt keinen Sinn, das zu Dauersuchten.
Es hat ja auch Geld gekostet.
Das heißt nicht, dass wenn du Geld genommen hättest, dass deiner besser ausgesehen hätte.
Aber deine waren schon durchaus okay, die Emotes.
Sonst hätte ich die ja nicht reingenommen.
Das machen wir heute.
Jun Squad, wenn du am Start bist, also wenn du am Start bist, können wir,
können wir, wobei, ne, können wir nicht.
Stripes, können wir nicht, können wir nicht.
Ich würde ja im Squad spielen, aber wir können nicht im Squad spielen,
weil angeblich das Squad-Einladen kaputt ist.
Post-Champ.
Squad-Einladen ist glaube ich kaputt.
Mit welcher Hardware spielst du?
Und SSD.
Aber wir können es probieren, wenn du willst.
Hab ich dich hier drinnen irgendwo?
Der CMD Krieger ist auch am Start.
Stripes 007.
Ist nicht auf deiner Freundesliste.
Rekt.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz, ich muss mir mal kurz Krieger-Aim geben.
Wartet mal.
Ich muss schon mal kurz Krieger-Aim angucken.
Zack.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt sehen, das muss ich jetzt sehen.
Hey, nicht, dass ich gutes Aim hätte mittlerweile in dem Spiel, ja.
Ich muss mir kurz Krieger-Aim angucken, Zack.
Zur Motivation, zur Motivation.
Das meint es doch nicht so schlecht ist.
Ach, das ist Controller, oder?
Das ist PC.
Ach du.
Okay, okay, Max.
Mein Aim ist fein.
Ich muss mich da, ich muss mich da nicht zu sehr verrückt machen.
Alles klar.
Nee, es ist nicht, es sieht nach Controller aus.
Aber unten, aber unten, unten war es PC, guckt.
Das ist PC.
Ist nicht Xbox und nicht, nicht PlayStation.
Ich hätte auch gedacht, dass er auf der, auf der PlayStation spielt.
Aber das Eigen ist PC.
Aber er spielt schon mal, aber er spielt schon mal den richtigen.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Er spielt schon mal den richtigen Held.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Controller am PC.
Ich dachte, das sieht man auch unten, wenn man mit Controller spielt.
Gibt es Auto-Aim auf Konsolen?
Angeblich ist es, ist es broken.
Es gibt kein Auto-Aim auf Konsolen, aber wird es mit Release auf jeden Fall geben.
Excellent.
Auf geht's.
Baschen, alter, baschen, baschen.
Huge Bash.
Spielen.
Schaut aus.
Zack.
Was muss man jetzt noch machen?
Ah, ich muss die Aufnahme wieder ändern.
Das muss ich aber warten.
Das ist mir hier übrigens.
Erst mal Rootkit starten.
Easy Anti-Cheat.
Das ist, glaub, das, was Apex auch verwendet.
Erst mal, erst mal das Rootkit installieren.
Aber jede Anti-Cheat ist mittlerweile, also jedes etwas inversive Anti-Cheat ist mittlerweile
quasi ein Rootkit mit Kernel-Service, Kernel-Modul und allem, was dazugehört.
True.
0W.
So.
Zack.
Jetzt müssen wir erst mal das Allerwichtigste einstellen.
Max, nerv dich der Twitch-League.
Da hab ich noch gar nichts zu gesagt bisher zum Twitch-League.
Habt ihr einen Friend-Request geschickt?
Zack.
Da ist er.
Kannst ja gleich gucken, ob du, aber ich kann dich auch gleich.
Ich invite dich gleich.
Der OpaPiecha69 ist auch am Start.
Dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr schiefgehen.
Ich invite dich gleich, wenn ich checke, wie es funktioniert.
Aber ich glaube, es ist broken.
Ja, es gab mehrere Paste-Bins.
Also mal ganz kurz, was sag ich zum Twitch-League?
Also ich hab da zwei Sichten drauf aufs Twitch-League.
Einmal aus Sicht von Twitch, bzw. aus Sicht von einem User und Streamer auf Twitch.
Es ist natürlich richtig hängen geblieben, dass Twitch zugelassen hat
und nicht die notwendigen Maßnahmen getroffen hat, dass es leaken konnte.
Es ist ja alles geleakt.
Der Source-Code ist geleakt auf Twitch.
User, Informationen, wahrscheinlich auch die Handy-Nummer, alles Mögliche.
Ja, alles Mögliche geleakt.
Das zweite ist, viele Streamer finden es natürlich kacke, dass ihre Verdienste und so jetzt rauskommen.
Da muss ich sagen, juckt mich nicht.
Im ersten Paste-Bin war ich noch unter den ersten 6000.
Hab ich selbst schon gedacht, das ist ein bisschen viel.
Mit knapp 100.000 in drei Jahren oder so.
Hab ich mir gedacht, das ist aber ganz schön viel.
Aber hab mir nichts weiter dabei gedacht.
Hab ich gesagt, okay, eventuell, aber nee.
Und jetzt im korrigierten Dokument bin ich tatsächlich auch nicht mehr top 6000.
Da bin ich sonst wo.
Hätte mich auch gewundert.
Liegt das an meinem PC? Nein, die Bilder läuft insgesamt schlecht.
So, also, Game Capture, das hier ausmachen.
Game Capture.
Musik aus.
Und jetzt machen wir mal den Sound lauter.
Was? Sound-Lautstärke-Test.
Zack.
Exzellent.
Ich glaube, das ist der beste Sound-Lautstärke-Test überhaupt, oder?
Auf geht's.
Ach so, ich wollte ja noch was in den Options gucken.
Und zwar angeblich kann man irgendwo...
Ah, das hab ich schon low.
Die Büsche und so niedriger Stellen.
Gibt es noch ultra low?
Es gibt nur low.
Nee, es gibt nur low.
Ich hab gedacht, es gäbe noch ultra low oder so.
Hat das, hat das, warte mal, hat das noch was anderes verstellt?
60, Motion Blur, nee, nee, passt alles.
Ja, übrigens, ich hab das Foff ein bisschen runtergestellt.
Ich komm mir wieder letzte Kacknup vor, aber 90 kam mir vor wie 120.
War das nicht?
Oh.
Ja, auf meiner 1080 Ti läuft's auch nice.
Bisschen problematisch wird's mit Stream zusammen.
Stand da 60-Herz im Menü?
Ja, das ist ein Bug.
Wenn du im Fenstermodus spielst, also in Borderless, Borderless Window,
dann, boah, was war denn das für ein Sound?
Dann zeigt das 60 an, obwohl, obwohl, passt auf.
Personalize.
Wartet mal, wo sieht man, wo ist der Kram?
Nochmal Display Settings.
Advanced Display Settings.
Dabei ist es 240.
Das ist, das ist gebaited, das gebaited, die Anzeige.
So, easy.
Ah, Runde geht sogar auch los, Poggers.
Poggers, Pogchamp, das wäre ein guter MMO-Name, oder?
Vorname Poggers, Nachname Pogchamp.
Wer will denn Boris spielen?
Wir spielen OP, wir spielen OP Setup.
Webster, Medic, Assault Rifle.
Das hier, perfekt.
So, und jetzt stellten wir uns in den Heli, oh, der Heli ist voll.
Anzeige ist raus.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Runner, Runner da.
So, jetzt erst mal checken, ob ich es irgendwie, das muss ich,
das muss ich noch ein bisschen üben mit dem Fallschirm.
Zack, was ist denn das hier?
Was ist das hier?
Da, ich mach, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Monka, Monka.
Dass ich den Fallschirm, ich ziehe den Fallschirm immer zu spät
und dann macht, boop, und ich bin, RIP.
Achtung.
Okay, nein, nein, null.
Das Geile ist, die Helis, entweder sind die alle zu blöd
oder die treffen alle nichts.
Sektor B ist an Attack.
Wo ist denn überhaupt Sektor B?
Was davon ist denn Sektor B?
Ich kann mir die Sektors nicht merken.
Ich mach jetzt einfach hier, zack.
Wir machen jetzt Dachstellts wie gestern, easy.
Ich sag's noch, ich mach's immer zu spät auf.
Bist du offline in Origin?
Ach so, ich wollte gucken, ob ich dich einladen kann.
Äh, wie macht man das, muss man da raus?
Ich hab noch keinen eingeladen.
Muss man da raus?
Weiß jemand, wie man Leute einlädt?
Okay, jetzt aber hier, auf geht's.
Hier.
Oh, da sind sie schon, da sind sie schon.
Guck mal hier.
Da wird schon gestellts.
Und jetzt aufs Dach, zack, bumm.
Man muss übrigens, es macht einen Unterschied,
ob man an die Ledge, die Ledge crappt oder...
Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Ihr wisst, was ich sage, wenn man an die Ledge crappt,
oder?
Mein Brain schafft es gerade nicht,
Deutsch und Englisch in Einklang zu bringen.
Jawoll, 02 geht gut los.
Also wenn man unterhalb von der, vom Anfang des Daches crappt,
dann fliegt man hoch.
Guck mal, ich zeig euch, was ich meine.
So, wenn man hier crappt, dann klettert man hoch.
So, wenn man...
Jetzt muss ich warten, bis der Crappling-Hook...
Haben die den Crappling-Hook langsamer gemacht?
Stripes, ich checke gleich, wenn ich hier raus bin,
ob das funktioniert.
So, aber wenn man hier oben hin macht, so an die Kante,
dann...
Okay, das war kacke.
Manchmal springt man dann hoch.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Panzer, Panz-Man, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Alter, das De-Synch, das ist auch was mit der Hardcore-De-Synch.
Habt ihr es gemerkt gerade?
Ich habe da drauf geschossen...
Oh, ist hier was?
Ich habe da drauf geschossen, es ist erstmal gar nichts passiert.
360, no scope.
Ach ja, beide meine Schüsse gehen auch manchmal durch.
Macht euch da mal keine Gedanken, wenn es so aussieht,
als dass es hittet und es hittet nicht.
Also, das ist normal.
Was ist denn das?
Viti, was?
So, wir gehen jetzt auf die Rakete, Leute.
Webster stellst du auf die Rakete.
Wir machen das jetzt wie Bezos, wir fliegen ins Weltall.
Wobei, war das überhaupt Bezos, der ins Weltall...
Ach, was weiß ich.
Hier stellst du was.
Ah, ah, ah, siehst du?
Schnell moving, Beste.
Oh, voll...
Also eins muss man hinsagen,
die haben es schon wirklich satisfying hingekommen.
Die haben es schon satisfying hinbekommen,
dass man, wenn man Gegner headshot,
das hört sich schon echt gut an.
Wobei, das hat nämlich sowas auch in Battlefield 1
oder Battlefield 5 dieses Bling.
Achtung, Achtung.
Oh, oh, oh.
Debated.
So muss das machen, Leute, ich sage es euch.
So muss das machen, so und nicht anders.
Guck, jetzt bin ich wieder...
Jetzt habe ich nicht die Ledge gekrappt.
Macht euch mal nichts über meine Pfeifett-Grammatik heute.
Ich kriege es nicht anders auf die Reihe.
So.
Gels FPS ist back, aber sowas von.
Guck mal da.
Nein.
Okay, easy mode. Achtung, easy.
Dann wird jetzt gebashed.
Oh, ich höre was rechts neben mir laufen.
Das ist ganz doof.
Bam, in your ass, man.
Ich bin dumm, ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Man kann jetzt einfach smack wechseln.
Wenn man smack wechselt, hat man eine neue...
Achtung, Achtung.
Weg, der wird weggestellt.
Der wird hardcore weggestellt jetzt.
Bam, man, jetzt geht es ab.
So muss das sein.
Guck mal, Hacker-Man haben wir gekillt.
Hacker-Man.
Was ist denn hier oben?
Es wäre cool, könnte man den Dude spotten.
Nein, du gehst weg.
Der will hier oben hin.
Guck mal.
Der denkt, der kommt damit durch.
Wenn du da oben rumstellst.
Übrigens, wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Wir machen jetzt Massive Trick.
Das wollte ich eigentlich nicht machen.
Ich wollte eigentlich herunterspringen
und dann rausspringen und mich hochcrabben.
Guck mal, jetzt zeige ich euch, was ich meine.
Ah, nee, ist noch nicht nachgeladen.
Also, passt auf.
Das meinte ich.
High Fat-Modus.
Hier ist, wo ist er denn?
Ist er da oben etwa drin?
Ist er da oben drin?
Oder nicht?
Nope.
Aber ganz oben ist er.
Irgendwo ist er doch.
Der hört mich eh nicht kommen.
Oh, schlechte Idee.
Ich glaube, wenn ich einfach gelaufen wäre, wäre besser.
Wo ist er denn?
Da ist er.
Achtung.
Das ist so OP.
Glaubt ihr mir jetzt, dass Webster einfach Must-Have ist?
Webster ist so OP.
Mit keinem anderen Specialist hätte ich das machen können hier.
Und habt ihr auch den Heli nicht gehört, außer als er auf mich geschossen hat?
Das ist immer so.
Du hörst die Dinger nicht richtig.
Machste nix.
Mojak Heli, ja.
Na, hier muss ich nicht liegen bleiben, als dass mich jemand retzt.
Retzt.
Ah, nee, da ist er.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Jetzt.
Okay, das war richtige 3-Head-Aktion.
Sag mal, die haben den Cooldown runter gemacht, oder?
Haben die den Cooldown runter gemacht?
Mir kam es so vor, als war der Crapling Hook gestern nicht so schnell ready.
Wo ist noch was?
Hier ist doch noch was in der Mitte.
Oder ist der Du...
In your ass, man.
Achtung, hier stellt einer.
Hier kann man übrigens richtig 3-Head-Klitschen an der Posi.
Wo ist er?
Boah, Monka.
Der fucking Turm.
Ich bin noch nie an dem Turm gestorben.
Premiere.
Der dumme Turm.
Warum?
Warum bin ich zurückgelaufen?
Der Turm.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man überhaupt sterben kann an dem Turm.
Übrigens, das hier macht mir mit Abstand am meisten Spaß an der Rakete.
Das Vertikale.
Dieser Vertikal stellt es hier.
Bin ich einfach nice.
Haben wir den Punkt eigentlich oder nicht?
Ist der da oben?
Nee, oder?
Wo ist er denn?
Wo bist du, Alter?
Stellst du den da oben?
Oh nee, ich bin stuck.
Ich bin stuck.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Aha.
Endstuck.
Ich höre hier noch was.
Hier hochzukommen ist halt auch so eine Lebensaufgabe.
Steht der da oben drauf?
Der schneibt doch da oben, der Kerl.
Komm mal hier.
Drei Stunden.
Und wenn einer hinter mir auf der Treppe stellt.
Sehr gut.
Nice, nice.
Genau so macht man es.
Nochmal, nochmal testen.
Sag mal, wo ist der Kerl denn?
Hier ist ja gar nichts.
Ich dachte, der macht hier krasse Stellzellen.
Da ist er doch.
Pass auf.
Ich finde es richtig dumm, dass das Third Person ist.
Weiß nicht, weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Achtung.
Jetzt wird sich angestellt.
Okay, RIP.
RIP.
Dachte nicht, dass der Hindere das checkt.
Da muss man, aber das ist eines der Sachen, wo ich wirklich sage, das ist cool in dem
Game.
Es ist oder zumindest war eine der Sachen, die man, würde ich sagen, die man mit der
Zeit so ein bisschen lernen kann.
Das Fallschirm, das Fallschirmzeug ist ein bisschen langsam, ja.
Aber das kann man wirklich gut timen, wenn man es kann.
Also, das hat ein besonderes Timing, weil das ist anders als beispielsweise in einem
Warzone Fallschirm.
Umso länger du fällst, umso mehr Speed hast du und umso mehr verzögert sich das.
Mal gucken, ob wir es hinkriegen.
Ja, perfekt.
Perfekte Pose.
Ich würde gerne oben auf die Rakete drauf.
Das ist nämlich richtig pock.
Fuck, immer im falschen Moment.
Moin, wie geht's?
Gut, nice, gebashed.
Ja, gerade, gerade letzten zwei Leben nicht wirklich, aber sag mal, ist der Typ afk?
Der steht die ganze Zeit da.
Und lässt mich spawnen?
Ich glaube, da ist afk, oder?
G-Security.
Ach, der drohend hier, der macht Drohnenstells.
Nein, Mann, warum kletterst du?
Hä?
Warum bin ich gerade umgefallen?
Was war das?
Warum bin ich umgefallen?
Komm mal, ich kann einfach immer bei dem Typ spawnen.
Meine Waffe war einfach weg.
Na gut.
So.
Ich höre hier was, aber man erkennt halt nicht von wo.
Aber der hängt da einfach nur, oh, ist noch was?
In the ass, Mann.
Wo ist denn der Typ?
Ist der, ist der Ander?
Oder wie soll man das nennen?
Nö.
Alter, wo ist der Gegner?
Wo ist der Gegner hin?
Der muss doch irgendwo sein.
Okay, ich check's nicht.
Hier wirst du halt von der Seite gleich gebashed.
Hier oben ist er doch angeblich irgendwo.
Zwei Stück, wir fliegen jetzt hier von der Seite rein.
Alter, Goblin-Hook, komm ready.
Hier ist perfekt, hier kann man nämlich dann easy rausstelzen.
Wenn das klettert.
Alter, please, Battlefield.
Lass mich klettern, come on.
Nein, Battlefield, ja, gut.
Der ist stuck.
Der hat das gleiche Problem gehabt wie ich.
Keck.
Keck weh.
Oh, oh.
Man sieht ihn gar nicht.
Ganz unauffällig der Dude.
Ganz unauffällig.
Hat man überhaupt nicht gesehen, dass er da lang kommt mit dem Fallschirm.
Hat man überhaupt nicht gesehen.
Nein, nein, nicht runterspringen, Mann.
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Ah, heute kriegen sie aber auf den Sack.
Raketenstells.
So macht, jetzt mal legit, legit Realtalk.
Findet ihr nicht, Webster ist, Opie ist, fuck.
Ich mein, die Mobility ist einfach hyper krass.
Also, weiß nicht.
Weil in meinem Video heute haben die Leute gesagt, nein, Max.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Mann, ich hab gedrückt.
Fuck, Alter.
Ihr habt's gehört.
Aber das ist wirklich brutal.
Sage ist besser, ja.
Wenn wir das richtige Game spielen würden, dann vielleicht.
Guck mal, der Typ ist immer noch afk an der Stelle.
Aber das an der Rakete macht wirklich, guck mal, 20.
Das an der Rakete macht wirklich Spaß.
Kannst nichts sagen.
Also, der Raketenstells ist wirklich spaßig.
Ah, nice, der Typ ist down.
Ist hier unten was?
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Hinter mir, hinter mir ist irgendwas, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wusst ich doch, schräg, Mann.
Hier kommt noch mehr, Achtung.
Von links, von links?
Ich muss mal ein Stückchen weg.
Ich muss mal ein Stückchen weg, ich hab Schiss.
Jaja, wackel noch mehr rum, wackel noch mehr rum.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist der Dude?
Ist er down?
Ich glaub schon.
Next.
Äh, Munition switchen.
Ihr seht ja, wie OP das ist, Munition geswitcht und easy, easy.
Oh, wir sind in der Mitte von Feinden gerade.
Wir sind zwischen 50.000 Feinden.
Und oben liegt irgendein Typ.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen, bisschen Distanz.
Da oben ist er.
Da oben ist er mit seinem Schneiberding.
Bin ich eigentlich blind oder gibt es kein richtiges Scoreboard?
Tja, es gibt das hier mit Kills für sich selbst.
Es gibt, wenn du hier auf Escape drückst und Squad gibt es dieses Ding hier.
Aber das ist halt, ehrlich gesagt, crap.
Hat sich Kaboom gemeldet wegen BF?
Nein.
Hätte er sollen?
Komm mal, ey, bester Spawnpunkt, Mann.
Oh ne, oh ne.
Hui.
Warum hab ich so wenig Schuss?
Weil ich die falsche Muni hab.
Falsche Muni.
Die hier brauchen wir.
Beste.
Ihr glaubst doch nicht, dass ich da drauf reinfalle, Kollege.
Ich wollte eigentlich ein Midi-Pack legen, aber hat keinen Bock.
Midi-Pack ist, Midi-Pack ist out, äh, Midi-Pack ist out.
Outdated.
Overrated.
Chebated.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Next, next.
GG Eats.
Ich muss gucken, dass der Sniper-Mann mich von oben nicht snipert.
Weiß ich, wo er ist.
Wo ist der Sniper-Mann?
Der wartet nur drauf.
Ich sag's euch, der wartet nur drauf.
Der aimt mich schon ab, wecken.
Der aimt, der aimt mich schon.
Guck mal, da ist er.
Fuck, da kann ich nicht durchschießen.
Ich find's definitiv nice, dass man da durchgucken kann.
Easy, GG.
Ist der grad runtergesprungen?
Wallbang.
Nice.
Der kommt doch nicht runter, der Typ, oder?
Da ist er.
Pass mal auf.
Vielleicht geht das.
Pass auf, der trifft.
Der trifft.
Jawoll.
In your face, Mann.
Richtig in your face, Alter.
Huge Nade, Massive.
ESL-Granate.
MLG-Legit.
MLG-Legit, Mann.
Oh, die Rakete startet gleich.
Das war übrigens absichtlich, ich wollte wieder runter.
Ich hab keinen Bock, da drei Stunden rumzustelzen.
By the way, jetzt spawnen 50.000 Gegner.
Jetzt muss ich wieder weg.
Sobald, sobald...
Sag ich doch, sobald du hier bist und die dich auf dem Radar sehen,
spawnen 50 Trillionen von unten kommt was.
Oder er hat da oben einen Spawn-Beacon.
Gibt's, weiß jemand?
Gibt es Spawn-Beacons?
Nee, oder?
Gibt keine Spawn-Beacons.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt Raketen starten, wir sind mittendrinne.
Wo ist der Dude?
Sagt mir, das ist nicht OP.
Oh, guck mal, bewegt sich das?
Ist die Startrampe gerade runtergefahren?
Oh, Raketen-Stells.
Massive Raketen-Stells.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich werde bestimmt noch gekillt vorher.
Ich versuche mich unauffällig zu verhalten, Leute.
Schießt schon was auf mich.
Versuche mich unauffällig zu verhalten.
Ich hab noch nie die Rakete starten sehen, wenn ich direkt drinne bin.
Wie lang dauert denn das eigentlich?
Wollen wir uns versuchen an die Rakete zu hooken, wenn die startet?
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Soll ich rauf?
Okay, ich geh rauf.
Die bashen mich wahrscheinlich, wenn ich rauf gehe.
Zack, Switch.
Äh, Alter.
Alter.
Da hat er nicht mit gerechnet.
Okay, wir sind oben.
Ich hoffe, da oben ist keiner mehr.
Ich hoffe, da ist keiner mehr.
Okay.
Wir haben Premium-View auf die Rakete.
Ich mach jetzt Trick 17-Versteck.
Nee, geht nicht mehr.
Oh, oh.
Ich hab das Problem, die springen über mir ab und bashen mich von oben.
Kommt mal, die sind schon auf dem Weg zu mir hoch. Seht ihr das?
Hallo, ich möchte springen.
Meine Leertaste geht nicht.
Ohne was?
Okay.
Wie lang dauert das mit der komischen?
Nein, nein, ich reloade.
Oh.
Oh, im falschen Moment reloadet man.
Rakete, komm on.
Flieg.
Ich versteck mich einfach hier.
Hier sieht mich keiner.
So, easy.
Ich aim jetzt die Ecke ab.
Ich aim einfach die Ecke ab.
Das halte ich eh nicht aus.
Rakete, komm on, please.
Ich bin nur noch hier, weil ich die Rakete einmal aus nächster Nähe starten sehen will.
Runde ist gleich vorbei, bis die Rakete startet.
Komm, Rakete.
Und dann schießen wir uns an die Rakete ran.
Nee, wir schießen uns nicht an die Rakete ran.
Sonst sieht man nichts.
Die Runde ist vorbei, bis die Rakete startet.
Ich glaube, die Runde ist vorbei, bis die Rakete startet.
Soll ich jetzt den Knaller zünden?
Den Knaller.
Come on, Rakete, please.
Bless RNG.
Muss man dafür was machen?
Das wird nichts mehr, ja.
Fürchte auch.
Komm mal, voll die Stats versaut.
Wegen Raketenstells.
Na gut, 36,9.
Kannst nicht sagen, versaute Stats sind schon ganz gut.
Check, wait.
Was hast du für einen Headset, einen Biodynamics MMX300?
Seit 10 Jahren oder so.
Oh nee, das dauert aber ewig mit der Rakete, Mensch.
Meinst du, dass Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4B das ähnlich im Arsch waren?
Tja, anders.
Battlefield 3 habe ich gespielt, closed sogar, closed damals.
Metro mit LLV.
Kennt kaum noch einer, wusste kaum einer, dass es immer ein LLV auf Metro gab.
Die war...
Die ging eigentlich halbwegs.
So, und Battlefield 4 war glaube ich auf Shanghai.
Die war auch relativ kaputt, aber im Großen und Ganzen hat man gesehen, was alles drin ist.
Und die einzelnen Sachen, die halt da waren, die waren halt noch verbackt.
In Battlefield 2042 ist es jetzt so, das Game wirkt wie eine Technik-Demo auf einer Sandbox-Map.
Ich glaube, das trifft es eigentlich am besten.
Der Countdown dauert 6 Minuten.
Also wir haben doch da doch lang gestanden, lang hätte es nicht mehr dauern können.
Wie kann man FPS anzeigen im Game?
Du kannst, machen, Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS, 1, dann hast du oben... Wo sind wir denn hier reingekommen?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Nein!
Wie macht man die Konsole auf?
Oben links, neben der 1. Was ist das? Zirkumflex ist das, glaube ich.
IC-Taste.
Zirkumflex.
Was ich für Aufsätze habe, meistens so hier.
Das, das, das, das.
Aber die Magazine switch ich durch.
Weil die Magazine Refuelen, Refillen, Refillen deine...
Das ist meine Gegner, das ist meine, meine Gegner, meine Gegner.
Okay, nicht meine Gegner, zu viele Gegner.
Die sind da oben.
Äh, what?
Up we go!
Granatuh!
What the?
Da ist was auf der Erde!
Nee, nee, weißt du, so leicht lasse ich mich verarschen, Kollege.
Nope.
Okay, den habe ich nicht gesehen.
Schreckt, Leute! Schreckt!
Tyrannosaurus schreckt!
Schreckt!
Noch mehr!
Nein! Fuck! Jetzt habe ich nicht hingeguckt.
Spawn Camping, was kann ich dafür, dass die Spielleader spawnen?
Hab ich das mitprogrammiert?
Ich kann da doch nichts für.
Ach ja, stimmt! Leute, wo ist eigentlich die Ping-Anzeige?
Wo ist die... das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Wo ist die Ping-Anzeige?
Wo ist der Ping?
Seriously, wo ist der Ping?
Oben rechts? Wo?
Hier kein Ping.
Müssen wir uns gleich nochmal angucken in Ruhe.
Komm mal hier! Komm mal hier!
Die Stelzer. Die Stelzer wieder.
Mein Medipack ist verschwunden.
Komm mal, das ist auf Cool Down. Mein Medipack ist weg.
Mein Medipack ist einfach verschwunden.
Warum?
Anzeige ist raus, Mann.
Links ist einer.
Die lassen sich ja so krass bashen heute.
Huge Bash. Massive Bash.
Basherino.
Ich werde jetzt vom Turm gestellt, ich sage es euch.
Ich versuche aber...
Nein!
Hilfe! Hilfe!
Ich kann mich hier in die Arme f**ken.
Richtiges Fallfett-Play, oder?
Übrigens, der Regen nervt.
Der Regen nervt.
Wo geht hier was?
Wo ist hier was?
Poggers-Play, müsst ihr zugeben, oder?
Schon ziemliches Poggers-Play gerade.
Was war denn das für ein Geslide gerade?
Wie bin ich denn da hochgekommen jetzt?
Alter, die werden ja heute gebashed as f**k, Mensch.
Ja, nicht sterben, please. Nicht sterben.
Sterben ist overrated. Outdated.
Pass mal auf. XXHD-Snipe.
Äh, ne, die will ich nicht.
Ich dachte, irgendeiner hat einen Sniper von denen.
XXHD-Snipe. Gibt's nicht.
I-Snipes. 360.
Moment, Moment. Leute, Leute, ich brauch mal die.
Ich brauch die passende Unterstützung dafür.
Excellent, jetzt geht's.
Mein Medikit ist wieder verschwunden.
Da kann ich nicht länger contesten.
Da waren drei Leute, die auf mich gezielt haben.
In your Kopf.
Midi-Pack? Meine Midi-Packs verschwinden die ganze Zeit.
Ich hör hier übrigens was.
Hier kommt ein Crapling-Hook. Ich hab grad einen Crapling-Hook gehört.
Oh nein, outplayed. Ich wusste doch, dass ich einen Crapling-Hook gehört hab.
Ich glaub, die fallen durch. Ja.
Ich hab teilweise... Leute, ihr müsst jetzt mal... Für einen 37-jährigen Boomer sind die Plays doch schon okay, oder?
Ihr müsst mir jetzt mal ein bisschen gut zureden.
Wo ist er?
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, schnell, schnell.
Okay, man kann ja durch nix durchschießen.
Ah, jetzt ist er down.
Ich bin ja ein Korean Chopper-Pro, genau.
Obviously Boomer-Faker.
Kein Falldamage, nice, GG.
Die sind echt okay. Okay, bin ich beruhigt, dass ihr das okay findet, dann ist das nice.
Three-Head, Three-Head-Hook.
Low-Brain-Hook war das.
Achtung, nein, fuck. Ich hab gedacht, ich hab den Crapling-Hook raus.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie aufs Dach komm nochmal.
Wo wir gerade bei coolen Plays und Aims sind.
Das war es jetzt definitiv nicht.
Irgendwo hier war was. Unten, unten, unten.
Nope.
Der muss hier sein. Der muss hier sein.
Von vorne kommt was. Oder nicht?
Von vorne kommt was. Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Ich hab keine Nades. Wo sind meine Nades?
Okay, man kann.
Also manchmal muss ich sagen, sind die Animationen zwischendurch schon ein bisschen...
Kann man mit dem Crapling-Hook Gegner ziehen? Nein, kann man nicht, kann man nicht.
Was macht meine Glocke da? Schießen im auseinandergeklappten Zustand.
Man kann keine Gegner ranziehen, aber der Crapling-Hook ist One-Shot.
Hab ich zumindest so gehört. Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Das wird jetzt was.
Captain Hook.
Captain Hook, Achtung. Jetzt muss ich erst mal nachladen.
Das finde ich geil, wie sie immer denken, sie können sich hinter irgendwelche Kisten stelzen.
Okay, Captain Hook angesagt.
Leute, soll ich den Chat eingeblendet lassen oder ausblenden?
Könnt ihr euch überlegen.
Kann man eigentlich auch so aufs Dach?
Okay, funktioniert.
Okay, Captain Hook. Wo sind sie? Wo sind die Gegner?
Wo sind die Gegner?
Ich will einen Gegner hooken und gucken, was passiert.
Ich glaube, die haben den Hook Reload ein bisschen länger gemacht.
Wo ist er?
Hier.
Nein.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Ich hab den gesehen, by the way.
Fuck, ich wollte jetzt den 5-Hit-Play machen. Ich hab den gesehen.
Ich hab gedacht, du triffst mich doch eh nicht. Ich wollte mich rüber hooken.
Okay, war blöd, war blöd.
Nein, nein, nein, du ziehst den nicht an, nicht ran.
Ich glaube, du one-shottest den Gegner mit dem Hook.
Spawn, Blitz, Blitz, Blitz, Spawn, Blitz. Nein, damn.
Die Gegner sind one-shot, du ziehst den nicht an, nicht ran.
Das ist kein Bulletstorm oder so.
Bulletstorm? Das Game kam nicht gut an damals.
Aber ich fand's für 5 Minuten Gameplay ganz witzig.
Oh nee, da geh ich nicht rein. Da geh ich nicht rein durch den Tunnel.
Tunnel wird gebashed.
Tunnel ist eigentlich Todesfalle.
Aber hier ist auch Kacke.
Nein, du sollst nicht hoch.
Ich geh doch unten lang.
Ich geh doch unten lang. Ich hab's mir anders überlegt.
Die spammen da Nades rein. Du hast eh keine Chancen.
Du kannst sie voll vergessen hier. Ich bin jetzt gleich tot.
Was ist denn das da, was da blinkt?
Ich hab mich schon 3 Kilometer weit gesehen, Alter.
Wie schnell war das denn, please?
Vielleicht rettet mich jetzt einer. Wir haben die Chance.
Vielleicht rettet mich einer. Es sind 5 Leute um mich drum herum.
Aber die spielen alle Webster, die spielen alle nicht Maria.
Tja, dann wird das mit retten nix.
Tja, mit Teamplay ist in dem Spiel nicht so viel.
Hier müssen wir hin. Hier müssen wir hin bashen.
Bashen, Alter. Bashen, bashen.
Massive bash. Achtung, 6-Hat-Time. 6-Hat-Time.
Fuck. Das wollte ich übrigens nicht wirklich runterspringen.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Hat nicht.
Aber es hat schon oft genug heute funktioniert, sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, next, please.
Okay, Respawn-Timer gibt es nicht. Oh, nee, da ist einer.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema kommen.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind.
Respawn ist unfair in dem Spiel.
Respawn ist unfair, as fuck.
Nix da. Warum?
So, und jetzt gibt es das Problem,
dass ich aus dieser Base nirgendwo hinkomme.
Guck, in dieser Base sind so gut wie keine Fahrzeuge.
Und der Drop von den Dingern funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
Oh, na.
Alter.
Oh, wir müssten eigentlich hier bleiben, die Droppen jetzt mit Spieler.
Oh, Stripe, sorry, ich hab dich voll vergessen.
Bist du noch am Start?
Oh, oh, oh, Kollege, fahr.
Yogo-Po, Massive-Teamplay.
Stripes, ich hab dich voll vergessen. Bist du noch da?
Da, okay, okay.
Chat, spammt mich voll. Wir sind bloß noch 200 Ticket.
Spammt mich voll.
Dass ich den Stripes einladen soll.
Webster ist so OP.
Ich muss sagen, es macht ja mega Bock, dieses Hook-Gameplay.
Es ist aber auch OP.
Schreckt, würd ich mal sagen.
Massive schreckt.
Und jetzt zieht man eh nix mehr, weil Sturmt.
Au.
Bist du weg?
Ich seh nix. Wo ist hier was? Unter mir.
Unter mir ist was. Da kommt was rüber.
Da kommt was rübergestellt.
Next.
Oh, hier ist was hochgekommen.
Nice, next.
Das ist jetzt Battlefield. So ist das nice.
Es knallt um dich drum herum. Du hörst, wo was abgeht.
Du stirbst nicht instant durch random Shit.
So, das ist nice.
Kill doch mal mit Grappling-Hook. Nee, das geht grad nicht.
Das ist grad nicht the time and place, das zu machen hier.
Nimm mich mit. Nimm mich mit.
Ich will in den Pants, man.
Oh nee, der Panzer geht kaputt.
Achtung.
GTA-Rollplay.
Ich hab ihn überfahren.
Habt ihr gesehen, ich hab ihn überfahren.
Ich mach doch GTA-Rollplay jetzt.
Habt ihr eine gute Idee für meinen GTA-Rollplay?
Wir brauchen ja da eine Name.
Wie könnte ich mich in-game... Ich werde nie GTA-Rollplay machen.
Aber wie könnte ich mich in-game nennen?
Gibt es da irgendeine gute...
Hat jemand eine gute Idee für?
Ich werde nie GTA-Rollplay machen. Ich hasse GTA-Rollplay.
Das ist überhaupt nicht mein Fall.
Ich gönne den Leuten, die damit Erfolg haben.
Aber ich mag es überhaupt nicht.
Max Brames. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Max Mustermann. Das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist so billig und plump, dass es eigentlich schon wieder gut ist.
Max Stelzermann.
Max Mustermann finde ich nice.
Aber nachdem ich eh nie GTA-Rollplay machen werde...
Da ist was. Guck mal da. Da ist er. Da ist er.
Wenn ich eh nie GTA-Rollplay machen werde, ist es egal.
Wir stellen uns da jetzt hoch.
Monka.
Und der hier.
Einfach.
Mein Midi-Pack hat wieder nicht funktioniert.
Sehr gut.
Wenn mein Midi-Pack funktioniert, dann macht es so einen Battlefield-Heal-Sound.
Ach, wie gerne würde ich spotten können, dass ich weiß, wo er hingeht.
Okay, Yolo.
Jetzt weiß er, wo ich bin. Jetzt weiß er, wo ich bin.
Man kann nicht spotten. Nein.
Funktioniert nicht. Ich habe die ganze Zeit gespottet.
Der hat einfach nur eine Marke auf die Map gesetzt.
Man kann nicht richtig spotten.
Das ist ziemlich dumm.
Ich habe null Ahnung, wo der jetzt ist.
Nein Nein Nein Nein Nein.
Was? Virus-Bust. Virus-Bust.
Das war noch nicht mal einer, der mich gekillt hatte.
Das war nochmal einquisierter Typ.
unpacken.
Zweimal schnell Q? Ich habe ganz schön viel Q gedrückt.
Das test ich jetzt aus!
Oh, die bashen uns mal richtig krass hier gerade mega halber besch
Der setzt einfach nur marker auf die map genauso wie ich das
Anker genauso wie ich das gerade die ganze zeit gemacht habe
Easy win
Oder flanken punkt ja das geht also du kannst mit kuh kannst du sagen wo du hin willst das funktioniert aber du kannst nicht spotten du kannst kein gegner spotten manchmal
Spottest du helis wenn du sie lange noch anguckst aber einfach spotten geht gibt's nicht ach sechs mal kuh drück
Ah verstehe ich glaube es sind eher 69 mal kuh
Oh man stripes einladen. Jop. Yep. Ich darf nicht raus zwischen der runde
Die in weitert man leute jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt sechs kopfzeit
Exit
Wollte eigentlich nur die q exiten nicht
Was uns zum nächsten punkt bringt das ui ist noch verbessern würdig
Wie ist deiner meinung zu dem instant insta insta spawn von aufsetzten im kampf
Ich finde es nicht so toll
Ich fand eigentlich dass in den vergangenen bettel viel relativ sinnvoll dass du dich festlegen musstest
Auf eine rolle die du spielen willst und dementsprechend mit passender
perk
passende klassen und passende
waffenauswahl
Weil aktuell ist es so du nimmst den assault rifle das ist auf jede range ganz gut
Und du kannst einen scope nehmen was es quasi noch mal verbessert auf range ist nicht dauernd es ging doch eben noch
Das ui ist müll sind wir mal ehrlich ja ich finde es auch nicht sinnvoll
Der recharge vom hochweg durch die distanz bestimmt das ist das ist clever das ist das ist clever
Das ist das ist clever das ist das ist clever so wie lebt man leute ein social
Party friends ne
PC stripes
In weit
Nein mir space vor in weit ist was ist für ein konsolen ui
Ich bin jetzt aus dem eiser kann man irgendwas
Wie macht man eigentlich sein kann man kann man schon irgendwie das ding editieren hier ne gel das wird nicht
Oh ist standardmäßig woib an und ich laber die ganze zeit mit den leuten in game
Ich glaube woib gibt es noch nicht
Woib ist aus
Ok stripes wir müssen jetzt mal testen ob das klappt mit dem suchen ich suche jetzt mal gucken ob du ob du mitkommst
Ist aus ok
Und ich dachte schon ich bin die ganze zeit meinen teammates jetzt hier in der stelle
Und ich bin jetzt in der stelle ich bin jetzt in der stelle ich bin jetzt in der stelle ich bin jetzt in der stelle
Und ich dachte schon ich bin die ganze zeit meinen teammates jetzt hier im stream
Auf den sack gegangen weil ich die ganze zeit voll texte
Wo sei ich irish
Er gibt es wahrscheinlich dann erst zum release als operator ich habe also wisst ihr was ich gehofft habe was leider nicht eingetreten ist
Ich habe gehofft dass die heute zur open beta noch mal was obendrauf legen was man machen kann
Ich meine ich habe die ins geheim habe ich mit einer zweiten map gerechnet aber eigentlich dachte ich mir schon dass das nichts wird aber insgeheim
Ich habe gehofft aber ich dachte mir die machen zumindest noch mal ein paar waffen oder ein paar operator rein
Weil so wie es jetzt ist wenn du das spiel sagen wir so 10 15 stunden gespielt hast hast du eigentlich so mehr oder weniger alles gemacht
Irish steckt noch in london fest wegen covid restrictions so ist das so realistisch ist das game also
Chat sagt wollte gerade mal ein beta anspielen leider absolut und spiel mal für mich habe sowohl auf ultra als auch auf low settings circa 40 fps
Heats batman
Wollte das nicht suchen jetzt
Hä
Ich habe da doch fünf mal drauf geklickt eben
Ich will das nicht verstehen
So ich habe ein game gefunden stripes mal gucken ob du jetzt mit reinkommst schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert ich habe gelesen auf reddit aber reddit ist reddit
Weiß man nie so genau das funktioniert nicht richtig
Reddit
Drei
Nee guck, es geht nicht! Oh doch, es geht doch!
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo- wo spawn sollen wir jetzt am besten?
Hier, D1? D? Das ist ein bisschen-
HQ? HQ?
Eh, fuck, warum ist H?
Da und-
Ääääh, zack, aufs Dach!
NEIN!
redeploy sorry redeploy ich hab vergessen die klasse anzupassen
das ist halt dumm dass das das netz speichert
ich sehs by the way nicht ein was anderes zu spielen ich will op shit spielen
schreibs ich, nein mach ich nicht
ich spawn bei b1 auf dem dach
b1 aufs dach
das da das da das da das da das da
und jetzt wird runtergejumpt
nicht nicht scaupen
steckt der hier fest?
jolo
kommst dir fast schon warzone mäßig vor
nein nein nein nein du killst mich nicht
achtung six hat time pass auf pass auf
was
moment
mit was hat er mich jetzt genau gekillt
mit war hat er eine rakete oder was war das mit was hat er mich jetzt mit der
granate
ja ist ja dumm
ach was soll ich werden gerätzt
guck mal leute
nein ich werde nicht gerätzt
das hat sich halt null nach granate angehört ich dachte das wäre irgendwie ein
raketeneinschlag gewesen oder so
hier vielleicht oh das ist hot
wo wir hier rein spawnen
das ist heiß
eigentlich müssten wir hier rüber
ok jolo
ich geh jetzt einfach rüber
da hinten ist der gegnerische pens man
der sieht mich schon nicht
panzer gär du siehst mich nicht
nein nein du siehst mich nicht du kannst mich gar nicht sehen ist unmöglich
ok ich erwarte nicht dass mich jemand rest
so wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin was ist denn hier
hier
sagen wir die beschriftung ist doch falsch oder
die beschriftung ist doch was
der ist gerade über mich gestellt
grappling hook
komm bei
der kommt links rum
pass auf der ist pickbrenner typ wir machen jetzt 6 hat move hier machen wir nicht
der ist gerade gestorben menschen
wie man hier fliegt
ist da oben noch einer
was schieße ich da einem in den kopf gerade
ok
was auch immer es ist autotaktisches sprint
spinten ja
ok ich check nicht wo hier was geht
wo geht mir was
unter mir
schreckt
ok ich habe kein bock hier oben zu kämpfen
gämmer mal
oft bei mausbett ist komplett verrutscht
hat er den plan was das gerade war
mit dem mit dem hook
was so gar nicht funktioniert hat
wo ich da hoch öpfen wollte
ja ich bin es ich bin es
alles gut richtig ab
so nah dran
also also vielleicht vielleicht so nah dran
urschweig gegräzt
achtung 5 hat move
aufwacht ich dachte man kommt hier rüber
das ist der komische hund
ok auch man kann rüber springen cool
und jetzt
jetzt können wir nirgends wohin
bei drei kilometer weit nichts ist
oben oben links
ich sehe nix
ist nix ist grau in grau es ist grau in grau
streit sich versucht zurückzukommen
aber du bist schon geräßt oder
egal schreit sich jetzt
hallo
die jeez
was hätte ich machen soll das dauert fünf stunden
aber was der hell
ich habe ne busch gekillt ja man hat nix gesehen
die runde ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn
aber trotzdem
es ist also man sieht halt schon so ein bisschen die probleme von dem gelb
drei stunden
für die vier
nicht hier wegfahren
hier muss man hier muss man beschen
wo ist nirgends
die käpfe doch hier oder
da kommt was
das ist bald
das ist bald guckt mal bitte auf die ne war kein bord
in den ähnlichen bord
der rannosaurus schreckt würde ich sagen
streit so bist du aber da unten
ich kann nicht retten die eben dich ab
ich probierst
du hast kein teamplan im spiel
wenn man nicht so ganz sicher
sehr abgeht
schreckt
aber ich ich sehe nix ist ist ist ist ist ist
ich habe keine ahnung wo hier was ist
jetzt sieht man wieder mein mein mein
kamer hier
hier ist auch so ein ding
sehr gut
angeblich ist hier was
hier wir stellen uns mal wieder weg
was ich mag ist
der fallschirm geht
schnell auf und zu
du kannst du kannst auch ganz kleine
sachen abfeder mit dem fallschirm fast schon fast schon ein bisschen zwei
das finde ich cool
ja ohne dvd sagt also hätte der mit dem richtig ordentlichen dvd in der
vorher aufladen kann
was er glaube ich nicht hat
dann
wer das alles noch ertragbar aber so
bei der wei pocker wer das
grau in grau man sieht sonst schon nix
wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin
map aufmachen geht nicht
hier hinten wird nix captured oder capture
die captain gerade dahinten oder
ist das plau oder was ist das
guck mal kaum bin ich weg
kaum bin ich weg
haben sie den haben sie den turm erstellt
fass ist nett
einmal mit profis
oh hinter uns hinter uns hinter uns sind sie gesporn
eine chance
sind sehr fair das gegner hinter einem sporn bei der wei
die hat spawns
ja clusterfuck ist angesagt würde ich sagen
sniper mit pistol amok ist der camper des crowns ja
wobei ich persönlich zum aggressiv spielen
ich ich finde webster ist
hallo ich möchte die zwei
ist opf
so dieses gucken von war das bettel viel
hier muss dieses gucken gab
das hier was meinst du das um die eck
die granate an nichts gehinten
wollte mich veräppeln
die granate war in seinem gesicht
die des tot
weg sniped
schwäck sniped von der rakete aus
panzer
der wieder runter gesprungen hat er tut hier war doch einer
heiler
keiner da
was macht der tunnel
extra ok
gab es im bettel viel eins
nene es gab um die ecke gucken definitiv
definitiv in dem bettel viel was ich gespielt habe gab es um die ecke
gucken ich glaube es war bettel viel vier
konnte man nicht in bettel viel vier leute
in bettel viel vier konnte man noch so machen guck mal hinter so ein ding
knien
und dann drüber gucken sensitive das ging doch war das war doch mal
ein bettel viel vier
also ich müsste also mein boomer hier ist nicht mehr so offen alle aktuellsten
stand das wisst ihr ja
aber ich spielte mir ein das war bettel viel vier
da unten kommen nicht durch
du hast hier keine ruten guck mal du kannst dadurch die klasse da fack
mitte
oder du kannst durch den klasse da fack tunnel eingang
was
was willst du tun
würde der echte gangster jetzt sagen
nichts willst du tun
wenn du mazio gäbe ich weiß
aber
ich weiß dass das geht
also erstens back das manchmal
ich mag dieses fette ding hier auf meiner waffe nicht
ich will lieber
der ist nicht gestorben doch
ich will lieber eckrassif hochaktion machen
und nachdem man nichts spotten kann ist halt auch
ok ich sag euch was wir jetzt machen
ja ist klar der geht nicht kaputt
wir machen jetzt
wir machen jetzt jolo stellt
so wenn wir angeschoss geschossen werden ziehen wir uns ran
wir haben es wir haben es fast geschafft hier easy easy jetzt jetzt respawn on me
respawn on me
ich würde gerne was spotten
mensch game
ist das was
das ist doch was
ich sehe es doch oder es ist ein busch
das wollte ich gar nicht so weit
nice nice nice
und ich sterbe
NA
schreckt
schreibt ich würde ich gerne retten ich glaube nicht dass es geht
also so machen die gefechte wirklich bock
das ist dann schon ziemlich intens gebäsche
aber halt auch aber halt auch
zu
extrem mit eins zwei gegen irgendwie 60 oder so
das ist einfach klasse fack oder nix los das ist der erste kritikpunkt den ich an dem
game hatte der steht immer noch
dieser klasse fack oder nix los
kann das sein dass die uns gerade ziemlich out
outplayen
die die leute hier
0,633 übrig
da ist einer hier
alter was ist das hier
ich will f drücken
f geht nicht
hinter mir ist ein panzer
der mich nicht gesehen hat warum auch immer
sieht wie Battlefield 3 in modern aus
ich lehne mich mal weit aus und wenn man sagt es sieht schlecht aus als Battlefield 3 aktuell
zumindest in low settings
wir schlagen uns aber tatsächlich ganz gut
für das dass wir
echt also wir werden
massiv dominiert guckt euch das mal an wir haben nur noch ein sektor wir werden
wir werden hyper dominiert
was
jetzt geht die kackwaffe leer ich glaube es nicht
scheibenwischer
am start wieder
voller scheibenwischer
please medipack aufpicken jawoll
jetzt sehe ich nix mehr
erst dauernd guckt guckt
was geht denn hier das ist jetzt neistes battlefield action hier drüben ist ein schneiber
wir werden wir werden so so destroyed gerade
hinter uns hinter uns
alter lasst mich durch manch mein hörtebring ist kein games not mehr da ist jetzt gerade
gebrochen
wir sind jetzt ziemlich exposed
vielleicht können wir noch was killen vielleicht kriegen wir noch was weg
ja hätte ich den jetzt hätte ich den jetzt spotten können
echt
diese drecks musik ja wir gucken gleich ob musik ausschalten kann
wir gucken gleich mal ob wir musik ausschalten kann die musik nervt mich auch
gleich muss musik muss musik weg
die haben uns heftig gebashed wir sind ja ins game gekommen das war schon das glaube
ich das game in der mitte
haben uns passabel noch geschlagen aber die haben uns wirklich
weggesnackt
wie man so schön sagt
wäre auch am start ja siehst du das max kann ich kanns mich adden oder ich kann dich
adden je nachdem
das erste was ich in dem game mache ist motion blur aus
und irgendwelche komischen vintage filter oder sowas
da hab ich ich hab jetzt nicht dran gedacht aber musik aber musik muss tatsächlich
weg
sound music volume zack
announcer ja gibt's da denn announcer
kameras shake
wo ist wo ist shake
das muss ich auch ausmachen weiß ich gar
kameras weg i get
monkaS
kameras shake
ne ne ne ne
musik
jetzt fack die rakete auch nicht mehr so hab die rakete startet eh so wenig
als battlefield soundtracks noch sich nach soundtrack angehört haben
so ich geh mal schnell den chat durch habe ich irgendwas übersehen a question
denkt dran schreibt entwumplos davor danke übrigens für die ganzen subs leute
ich hab's
heute das überfordert mein altes gehirn
zu spielen und mcfly danke für den sub und zu sehen wer subscribt
du vermisst den battlefield 3 medic train ich auch auto tech sprint ist standard
sogar
glaubt ihr die machen einen tag länger
nee die wurden genug geflamed
geht dann nicht die wurden genug geflamed für die bitter ich glaube die haben keinen
bock mehr ich glaube die die
gehen als erst mal in schweden
in irgendeine in irgendeine therapie nachdem die so krass also ihr müsst mal gucken
reddit twitter youtube
außer halt die üblichen verdächtigen die generell bei allem den leuten in arsch
kriechen
ist die kritik schon unüberhörbar
muss muss man muss man sagen
und ich glaube
aber ich würde gerne spornen wenn das möglich ist
im heli
sind wir über dem haus oder nicht
ach ja
es wäre zum beispiel cool zu erkennen was davon freuen und was da feinde sind
ich
ich weiß dass man das an den blauen punkt erkennen soll aber der blaue punkt
backt
wo ist der
da unten etwa
der ist der etwa hier rum
ok
ich blicke nicht durch was sie abgeht
man hört nur die man hört nur die einschläge und sonst nichts
ist es ein gegner
ok achtung
und kanzeln
und zack
jawoll so muss das sein
ach wir haben das hier ja schon
das ist ja easy wir haben das schon
ok wir versuchen noch mal durch den clusterfuck tunnel
wo ist das stripes eigentlich
irgendwo da
ich bin ganz woanders gespawnt
vergiss es
es ist aber auch in dem game schwierig zusammen zu bleiben
dadurch dass du nicht wirklich richtig wiederbeleben kannst
ist halt schon so ein ding für sich
so achtung clusterfuck tunnel am start
massive
ich sehe nichts
pack
ok wir haben sie hier glaube ich gebashed
da hinten ist was gelandet
achtung achtung
krieg 17 massive massive trick
game
please
lass mich einfach spielen
das game wollte zu mir sagen spawn bei deinen teammates glaube ich
stripes ich spawn jetzt einfach bei dir rein
es wollte sagen spawn bei deinen teammates
ja eigentlich wollte ich runterspringen und dann mich aufs andere haus rauf hucken
weil dahinter weil ich dahinter einen fallschirm gesehen habe
den trick hat keiner kommen sehen das ist richtig so
nicht mal die entwickler selbst
ich mach jetzt ich mach dir im nächsten video 5 battlefield tricks die nicht mal dice kennt
wie funktioniert die mechanik mit dem drop
normalerweise drückst du b und sagst du willst was haben das problem ist nur dass
das ist dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert
wie so ziemlich fast alles andere in dem game
aber es funktioniert nicht
mit den jobs wäre das etwas erträglicher ist was ist was ist einer von uns
mit den jobs wäre das tatsächlich etwas erträglicher
dann könnte man jetzt hier nämlich einfach irgendwo hin und müsste nicht
drei kilometer laufen ohne dass was passiert
funktioniert einwandfrei
easy ist es eigentlich gar kein problem
das alles ist es ist alles ein bildung
in wirklichkeit ist alles perfekt
alles andere ist fake news leute
ihr wisst ja wenn irgendwas ist was einem nicht passt einfach fake news
haben wir jetzt haben wir ja oft genug jetzt schon gehört
wo geht hier überhaupt was ab ist ja gut mensch
ist er tot
ich würde übrigens gern mal gegner sehen diese runde
da ist was
was ist denn hier los gerade
was passiert hier
wo ist er denn
oder stripes macht tunnel action
nein das war so nicht geplant
wechsel vor auf single burst nein v wechsel auf single tap
burst gibt's glaube ich bei der
pistole
das ist dann ganz gut
rennt in den clusterfaktor jetzt geht's ab gachi bastheim
gachi bastheim guckt euch das mal an da oben schon
jetzt war meine eigene
gachi bastheim
hier kannst du nichts machen ich sage es fehlt komplett an flankmöglichkeiten
oder ich habe noch single schuss
gachi basturm
moment ich habe gestorben was war das denn jetzt
ich blick hier nicht durch das mit so hoch
die spaß spacken darum sieht laufen aus wie die bewegen
wir kommen nicht durch das kommt mal das ist brutal eng was haben die sich bei der
map gedacht keine flankmöglichkeiten achtung achtung 360 time
bei fat mode
von hinten kommt was
kommst du um die ecke komm um die ecke
bei fat jawoll
da war was
das waren zu viele das ist halt das ding das kannst du machen gegen 32 gegner
kannst du nicht machen gegen 60 gegner
ok ich weiß es sind nicht 60 aber ihr wisst was ich meine
du kannst nur bis zu einem gewissen punkt die gegner die gegner out
out five hätten
mehr geht nicht
das ist bestimmt im haus was hier abgeht oder
hier oben auf der plattform tatsächlich hier oben auf der plattform
ich bin nicht ganz sicher
der blaue punkt kommt übrigens auch zu spät manchmal weißt du nicht was sache ist
hier unten sind welche ich sag euch die sind hier
guck guck
jetzt jetzt bräuchte ich meine neid noch
ecken stellts jawoll
ecken stellts
ok jetzt ist der stripes ist drinne ich gebe mit
geschreckt man
stripes ich retz dich
pip
poggers play
so muss es sein
tatsächlich bei mir übrigens den katter gemeldet vor einer weile und ich habe
den gefragt ob dem ja aus dem stream von gestern ein highlight so und so und so
und zehn minuten highlight oder so bauen kann
finde es ist eine gute idee mal gucken was dabei rauskommt
oder auch vielleicht aus dem glaube das ist ganz praktisch das kann ich nämlich
als gameplay verwenden
einfach so zum abschluss einfach so zum abschluss sagen wir kommen die immer
noch die gleiche treppe hoch einfach so zum abschluss der beta
die da unten ist nichts mehr kann nichts mehr sein
doch vielleicht da oben
ok wir gehen hier wieder runter
dein pc schafft nicht mehr als 30 fps feels bad man
oh moment warum ist man perf overlay aus
trau ne perf overlay trau fps eins jawoll
wait a minute
ich wusste der fallschirm hatte ich aber war so cheap baited ich wusste schon drei
kilometer wo er sitzt max mit seinem uralt gaming pc ist das dieses apex
legends du meinst das hier ja so ein bisschen schon hat ein bisschen was wie
heißt der typ noch mal in apex wobei ein apex ist natürlich noch heftiger
jetzt ist dieser robot ein apex ich habe apex nicht wirklich gespielt
passfinder genau
und ein shit
das war pp gar systema leute der play war gut aber der grappling hook ist
kaputt gegangen wenn ich auf dem dach gelandet wäre was ich eigentlich vorher
hatte hätte es richtig was gebracht also der grappling hat schon ein bisschen
was von apex ja ok aufs dach aufs dach und dann runter jumpen
wie machen wir das jetzt kommen wir probieren es nochmal jawoll stripes
perfekt excellent
nein man das pistol switching dauert auch so lange wie lange behält man seine
waffen konfig für die runde für die runde leider leider deswegen sporn ich
immer deswegen sporn ich immer mit dem falschen doch doch du behältst die waffen
konfig für die runde wenn du die richtige war für spiel bei der hier
behältst du die waffen konfig bei der ak nicht wie gibt es ein fps overlay
perf overlay punkt pro fps eins exakt das gleiche wir müssen besporn die
capturen b oder unten kommt was wieder nicht gestorben monka
ecken stellt da ich bin der ecken stellt meister mich stellt keiner so schnell
aus ok doch die hat mich ausgestellts
bisschen später beschen was bisschen später wird nice puden puden ist auch
so ein geiles wort essen essen ist outdated heute puden man
köttbäller bei ikea
kott kött köttbäller buller alles alles dauernd
tja wo haben die gegner noch was dahinten nur oder nur sonst wo am arsch
der welt oder da
also muss der hier vorhalten auf du links ist einer ein lass mich
ohne dass das auto schreckt in der kopf ich schätze ich nicht
schreck next please sind glaube ich auf der anderen seite kann es sein oder sind
die unter mir ok hinterher hinterher hinterher
hinterher jetzt muss er wissen dass ich hinter ihm bin
der muss hier rein sein ich wusste das war der gar nicht
ich glaube das war ein anderer achtung achtung achtung schrägt man ja wohl
läuft doch 37 jähriger boomer best junge try hard das wäre mein videotitel
oder so sollten wir das man 37 ja alter warum klaut mir das immer keiner wenn ich
sagte es 50 mal in jedem video in jedem stream aber alle sagen 37 ich glaube es
ist aber überlegt mal überlegt mal es sagen genauso viele leute also max videos
voll nostalgie habe ich vor zehn jahren geguckt so und jetzt überlegt euch mal
wenn ich vor zehn jahren am start war und da schon was erzählt habe über irgendwie
ausbildung und sonst was muss ich schon 37 jähriger boomer sein anders geht das
ja gar nicht sonst würde es ja auch nicht funktionieren das hast du dir
anders vorgestellt oder
stripes ich würde gerne mit dir zusammen spielen aber es ist schwierig
weil in dem game ist irgendwie so teamplay so ein bisschen pepega oder
kommt was was ist hier was das einer von mir wie ist eure meinung zum neuen
battlefield ich kann keine emotes einblenden
weil ich fullscreen game habe also die immer massig viele probleme immer extrem
viele probleme also ganz ehrlich ich persönlich dachte eigentlich die sagen
noch wir verschieben das game ein halbes jahr aber das herr also nicht jetzt
sondern ich dachte das sagen die bei der letzten ankündigung haben sie aber nur
ein paar monate verschoben vielleicht sollte ich mal was machen anstatt hier im
kreis zu laufen ach guck mal bei der wege kommt mit ich zeig dir was weiß ich
ob du schon kennst pass mal auf wenn ihr hinten hochwollt ist es total einfach
wenn ihr hochwollt ihr könnt die treppe laufen und wir werden nein nein lass
mich ohne es dauern hast du schon ausführliches review ja wahrscheinlich
zeig euch mal was passt mal auf wenn ihr aufs dach wollt ihr könnt hier hochlaufen
ihr könnt aber auch einfach hier hinten hingehen und warzone style fahrstuhl
machen dauernd aber nur eine halbe minute bis man oben ist wo man auch wieder den
unterschied ist zu alten bettel viel zieht hier ist die skalierung ungefähr
oder ist was direkt neben mir ok da machst du nix keine chance da machst du
nix immerhin immerhin noch eingebäst vielleicht kann ich vielleicht kann ich
bei stride spawnen wir haben es schon so jetzt machen wir raketen stellts leute
ich sag es euch mersif raketen stellts wir stellts uns jetzt an zur rakete und
machen wieder machen wieder gerüst action
den habe ich zu spät gesehen habe es auf der map gesehen höchste nicht was
möchtest du deine setzt auch mal binden was habe ich angefangen und nicht
beendet ach skalierung also man sieht dass es im vergleich zu den alten
battlefields jetzt halt von der skalierung her relativ eins zu eins ist
oh in der in der lagerhalle ich sehe nix im alten battlefield waren die
heuser kleiner und sowas halt mehr spielbarkeit nicht wirklich maßstab und
hier ist es ein bisschen mehr maßstab mäßig die heuser
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich mein der kommt gleich hier hoch
ok ja man verstand was ich mein also ein bisschen wie bei assassins es ist ein
bisschen wie der sprung von assassins creed 2 zu assassins creed 3 in
assassins creed 2 waren die heuser auch klein weil man nicht rein konnte und
wenn ihr mal die heuser mit assassins creed später vergleicht wo man in die
heuser rein konnte sind die heuser viel größer geworden weil es halt ansonsten
von der skalierung her nicht gepasst hätte so und hier ist auch alles größer
und es sieht jetzt von der skalierung realistischer eins zu einsiger aus im
vergleich zu den alten battlefields da war das halt alles ein bisschen stripes
ich glaube ich kann dich nicht retten wenn ich dich rette dann ich glaube ihr
versteht was ich meine deswegen deswegen haben sie sich halt gedacht wir machen
halt die skalierung größer also mehr mehr Richtung realismus aber ich weiß dann
nicht ob es dem spieler am ende gut getan hat weil das ist alles viel größer
viel weit räumiger und es läuft halt darauf raus dass es entweder clusterfuck
ist oder op clusterfuck oder nix los so wie jetzt
hallo please game
nichts da warum ist da nichts da
weiß ich so genau von von wurde
das war nicht so aber das auch schwer zu treffen
links neben mir war glaube ich noch was und die rakete ist wieder am start
die rakete muft die rakete muft
in der kopp der dude hat echt glück gehabt ist er oben
vielleicht sehen wir jetzt die rakete starten aber ich glaube es nicht
glaube wir sehen nicht die rakete starten wir haben dafür viel zu wenig
zeit wo sind sie wo sind sie wo seid ihr wo sind die kleinen pp gas wo sind sie
wo sind sie nicht da keine pp gas da
irgendwo ist ja noch was oben oder wo sind die denn stellst du unten
nee ok ich blicke nicht mehr durch weiß nicht wo was ist haben wir die hochfahren
geht das der fahrstuhl fahrstuhl stellst
ich bin noch nie mit dem fahrstuhl hier gefahren geht glaube ich auch nicht
ist der der ist da oben leute ich sags euch ich sags euch der ist da
oben der ist 100 pro ganz oben
der sitzt da oben in seinem sniper tower und freut sich des lebens du kannst
nicht mehr mit der gtx titan richtig spielen ich habe mit ich habe mit
1080 di das ist jetzt nun wirklich nicht top modern high end oder so
hört ihr hört ihr ihn über mir schon hört ihr sie die kleinen pp gas da oben
die kleinen pp gas möchte aus dem belle paradies abgeholt werden
da sind noch mehr wo sind sie denn ok es war nur einer das sah für mich aus als
waren es mindestens drei auf der map
aber das sind tatsächlich mehr nein warum ging der hook nicht junge messer
ihn doch nur warum die animationen sind so langweilig mittlerweile mit der
third person bestien lieber ich habe vorhin eingemessern das hat mich überhaupt
nicht befriedigt ihn zu messern
ich sehe lieber ab so und nun wohin a1 ok auf gehts
guck mal übelst unfairer spawn die jenna sind jetzt vor uns und wir spawnen von
hinten
hätte ich den mal spotten können unter mir ist einer
ich weiß ich habe es gesehen muss gucken wo er stellt gleich stellten sich hier
raus da werden sie gebäscht ist er gut nein ich habe ihn noch gekriegt habt es
gehört bling am ende noch
bling jetzt sagt bisher muss ich sagen ist bettel viel fünf wesentlich besser
ich kann dazu nicht sagen ich habe bettel viel fünf kaum gespielt lat mal ein
mache ich habe ich dich auf euch dich auf origin ok
du findest lächerlich dass man es nicht starten kann
naja ich glaube amd leute also leute mit amd grafik hatten auch mehr probleme amd
hat gesagt sie aktualisieren treiber nicht pc peng
hast du gekriegt oder soll ich bei dir joinen
ihr passt aber ich sonst noch jemand von euch
ja also es ist eigentlich fast egal welche welche grafikate du hast
habe ich dich du hast anfragen geschickt seck hier vielleicht kriegen wir dich
noch schnell rein jetzt seht nein fuck da nächste runde ich will jetzt nicht
raus weil du kannst wahrscheinlich nicht mit party raus ok es soll package
medic die anderen was sagt alles wir können nicht viel mehr spielen
ich mache kurz die musik aus sechs leute so also den da den da den da den da
wobei so passt das excellent excellent so als kommt gleich die gegner hier
lang geflogen aber das kaptur arst treibst schon am start und kaptur ich
dachte es mir doch ich wusste dass da in den pippen das ist nicht so glücklich
gelaufen ok wisst ihr was wir gehen zur rakete kommt heute wir gehen zur
rakete mal gucken wie weit ich komme wir gehen zu rakete die rakete ist schon
gecaptured haben wir alles gecaptured
wir gehen wir gehen zur rakete kann es sein dass wir das komplette game
gecaptured haben gerade und die gegner sind oder so ja wir haben das komplette
game gecaptured keine gegenwärme er kommt was natürlich auch von uns das ist
was ihr für eure cpus braucht können das spiel auch spielen ja das game ist
doof
das ist blöd ich kann euch übrigens noch was zeigen
guckt mal also die haben sich schon ein bisschen was bei gedacht mit der
bewegung über die map also es ist nicht permanentes gerennen aber es ist halt
ziemlich ziemlich viel gerettet du kannst an vielen stellen da halt hoch
das ist halt langsam und dann kannst du nicht rüber zippen zum beispiel da
rüber oder halt auch hier runter ab sein so wo gehen wir denn mal hin alles es
ist alles es ist alles grün base rape würde ich mal sagen base rape time auf
geht's easy
mach so muss ich auf die spitze der rakete ich habe das schon probiert also
ich habe mehrfach versucht auf die rakete zu kommen und ich bin immer
abgerutscht mit dem grappling hook aber c was davon ist c das ist a
wir verlieren c was was hier vorn ist c map ich brauche nur map aber es gibt
keine map
jetzt meine frage an den chat ich gucke gleich rein ich habe sie nebenbei hier
auf zwei jesus dann für den sub meine frage an den chat jetzt wo ich wo ich es
alle spielen können was sagt ihr visibility ist so gut in dem spiel so
gut so gut so gut
und nachdem ich nicht spotten kann keine ahnung oder hinten sind gegner
wo ist man squat ich weiß nicht wo man squat ist da hinten ich komme heute ich
bin auf dem weg aber ich glaube bis ich ich bin erst in 250 meter bei euch so
eine mischung aus kot und apex ja ich finde man merkt dass da apex mit
geschwungen hat gerade bei dem grappling hook ich finde das ist oder oben kommt
was
schreckt in your ass man auf fack hinter mir ist noch was nein
vielleicht habe ich glück meine team jetzt haben die gebeten
team play leute pockers in den chat für team play pockers in den chat oder pock
oder irgendwas sachen gibt's die gibt's ja gar nicht die gibt oder koppepanzer
sachen gibt sie gibt's gar nicht ich ok du rettest ich eben ab
massive pock team play pock
oh der pence man der pence man der direkt direkt vor mir
jawoll der panzer ruckel ein bisschen
pgm wenn es jetzt apex wäre konnten wir hier den die slider action machen wenn
das apex wäre können wir die slider action machen bis ins tal möglichkeit
zwischen der x 12 und 11 zu switchen eine gute frage ich weiß es nicht
ich glaube nicht
den juchten der tornado oder die raketen ja da ist tatsächlich was dran
ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich fand es also ich war glaube ich einer der ersten
noch zu release als alle von gehyped waren von diesem tornado gesagt hat ich
wette mit euch wetter fack mich ab und ich glaube sie immer noch weiß nicht
genau worauf ich ziele das ist nicht nur das kann ich kann ich nicht
challenge na ich eile warum hat es nicht gehitet
what the fuck man kann man hier ich sehe nicht ich aber das war von mir
ppega nicht gesehen
okay da sind wir wieder viele kugeln durchgegangen
okay stellst
nope die pack 8 8 oder die werden die werden abgestellt
leute die werden huge abgestellt von oben vom dach
heißt es glaubt wir haben es gleich
die pack wisst ihr wie op das ist dass ich die mobility habe und das medipack
vielmehr op geht ja gar nicht
medipack und mobility und die besten waffen und squad mates retten alles klar
wachs tatsächlich eine anzeige für fp stippen ich check auch nicht was die
anzeige bedeutet es ist fps durch millisekunden also von der ideen mal
1000 und man hat hier fps was aber was fps durch sekunde also frames per sekunde
durch millisekunde es ergibt jetzt wenig sind ist es eine beschleunigung frames
pro sekunde pro millisekunde beschleunigung ich habe keine ahnung
es ergibt wenig sind die anzeige
was ist das denn für plötzlich ja plötzlich für ppega battlefield kam
wahrscheinlich wenn man weiß was es bedeutet ist ganz einfach
das ist wahrscheinlich frame time oder sowas
aber ich finde die anzeige trotzdem irgendwie komisch kann es sein dass die
gegner brutalst zerstört werden gerade dachte das verdammte spiel was gesehen
gerade dass die massiv zerstört werden also nicht einfach nur ein bisschen
zerstört sondern dass wir quasi die hälfte der tickets an vorsprung haben
das irritiert auch dass du leute hast die sich auf den boden wälzen und du
nicht weißt dass gegner sind oder nicht die sich die sich das könnte auch
gegner sein die griechen auf den ersten blick
gegner da hinten sind geschnoss ich seh es wie das nicht da
gegner basten alle basten passen auf huge stelz huge stelz
massive stelz big brain stelz
nachladen ich habe kaum noch muni
da kommt gleich was
haben wir noch ein bisschen muni hier irgendwie jawoll ja man muni
alla what the hell stripes ist der weg
er ist auf dem dach oder nein
müsste ich dachte er ist auf dem dach
ist er dauernd ich hoffe mal
machts dir bock ja aber das liegt witzigerweise weniger an dem battlefield was ich wie battlefield
spielte sondern da ich die mut dass ich die movement machine mit webster übelst nice finde
dieses danke für die ganze zapps leute läuft es flüssig naja geht es ist schon ok es ist
jetzt nicht super flüssig näher bringt überhaupt nichts also sich super flüssig aber es geht
taktischer sprint ist übrigens irgendwie manchmal auto und manchmal nicht eben muss
ich drücken eben muss ich drücken und manchmal muss ich nicht drücken jetzt ist taktischer
sprint nicht auto jetzt ist taktischer hä verstehe nicht zack das muss ich mal kurz
abchecken taktischer sprint options controlled auf wo ist denn das jetzt ich habs ich habs
letztens erst gesehen on foot hier double tap double tap sprint forward to sprint ja
oh lull damit hat er nicht gerechnet leute damit hat er nicht gerechnet dass der max
im busch sitzt und kämpft und settings guckt was all das war drei schuss in kopf und dann
ihm hätte schon jetzt sagen wir mal wie hat er das überlebt ich hab dem grad wirklich
drei vier fünf schuss in kopf verpasst nein kein bock hat einfach nicht registriert denke
ich leute und das ist auch so ein pump wo ich sage der finde ich nicht gut du siehst
nicht ob freund ob feind rum rum also gut dem fall squad aber wenn du hier leute rum
rennen hast sogar wenn du wenn du mannix rumrennen hast die sind blau und die sind blau egal ob
vom eigenen team oder vom gegner team dass du kannst sie einschätzen richtig die gegner
krieg ich schon richtig heftig auf und sagt wir rennen immer nach hier hat die gehen
durch den tunnel oh nein oh meine muni ist leer nein ich brauche midi pack ich brauche
midi pack gibt mir ein fucking mini pack ok muni leer muni nächste markt nächstes merk
ok das war zu viel das war zu viel was soll ich denn noch machen normalerweise mit 32
spielern wäre die chance dass es jetzt endlich mal vorbei gewesen wäre nach fünf kills
durchaus gegeben bei dem krassen respawn und und 64 gegner keine chance jetzt drücken
sie aber jetzt drücken sie aber hier für dass das die ebenso gesagt haben ja ich habe
auch problemen mit dem aim richtig siehst du ich habe teilweise richtig das liegt daran
dass ich 6 37 jähriger boomer ohne ein bin aber ich habe teilweise auch die übelste
die übelste scheibenwächer geschichte in dem game in anderen ist es nicht so schlimm
bei dabei wo ist man ach da hin ok ich bin ziemlich pepega gesporn glaube und der ist
im tunnel der ist tunnel stellt ok ich habe versucht alles zu killen ging nicht ich habe
gedacht es geht wenn ich feuer irgendwie spreader aber nope jetzt kann ich wenigstens bei meinem
team spawnen das game wandelt ein aim in analoges movement ja ernsthaft ich könnte mir das
tatsächlich vorstellen ich könnte mir das legit vorstellen bei dem game es fühlt sich
sehr schwammig an ich könnte mir das legit vorstellen dass das so ist ich meine es war
jebaited aber ich könnte man das game rauskommen in man kommt das game raus drei wochen oder
so das ist niemals ready das game in der form schreibst ich hole dich bis gerade verschwunden
oh oder pence man schreckt ok guck mal kaum ist an der fahne was los sport hier ich spawn
hier achtschleute achtschleute vielleicht sehen wir jetzt mal die rakete starten von
wo bestimmt hier oben chat sagt ich hoffe einfach das ganze fix fix wird fühlt sich
schwammig an wie bei einem free to play game ein bisschen ja gebe ich dir recht ein bisschen
ja angeblich das bild wird ja immer älter am anfang haben sie gesagt etwas älteres
bild und jetzt bei uns haben schon gesagt altes bild jetzt ist irgendwie rum geschnitten
sieben monate altes bild aber das halte ich schon für ein bisschen übertrieben warum
sollte man uns ein sieben monate altes bild spielen lassen ja ich glaube wir müssen
hier weg ist nix passt mal auf der turm ist übrigens auch backt seht ihr wie der turm
rum ruckelt du kannst motion sickness du kannst nicht nicht spielen so unmöglich guckt
euch den turm an keine chance die lassen sich so nice outplayen ok jetzt hier aufs
dach sind gejumpet ich sag doch leute ich habs heute im video gesagt ich habe im video
gesagt webster ops fack und die leute auf youtube wieder max nein nein nein das stimmt so nicht
eigentlich ist alles ziemlich gut webster ist nicht zu stark überhaupt kein problem
nein nein by the way medipack so nicht kolleg wo ist mein medipack warum mein medipack
soll reloaden ok keine chance es ist unfassbar wie das wie das op natürliches op die zipplein
hat angeblich eine unterschiedliche cool down versus länge wie man wie man sich ran zieht
so stripes ist da wo ist der captain peng the dead aber stripes rein a stripes in combat
was ist captain poggers es ist mega op ihr seht doch ich meine es ist jetzt nicht dass
ich hier irgendwie jetzt den ultra mega competitive tryhard sonst was modus anhabe vor allem
in meinem alter wird es auch ein bisschen schwierig und trotzdem easy easy runden da ist er ach
du bist immer noch auf der rakete ok stripes wir können uns aufs haus raus aufs haus rauf
hintenrum also wer das nicht kennt man kann auf das haus kann man hintenrum das ist richtig
wir sollten es zusammen wir sollten so zusammen hochstellen kann man hier kann man sich zipplein
jetzt und dann geht man oben hin und best was können überhaupt die anderen operators
werden ich euch sagen du hast einen medic der kann leute mit der pistole heilen und hat
100 prozent rätts
zack das ist übrigens auch so ein ding clusterfuck oder nichts hier ist nichts los sobald wir
das capturen es spawnen jetzt 30 leute leute passt auf es spawnen gleich 30 leute hier
rein während wir das capturen es ist so du kannst nichts gegen machen und predictable
wo die spawnen die spawnen überall um dich um dich hinter dir unter dir normalerweise
spawnen sie jetzt da sind sie schon in dir spawnen sie spawnen in mir genau gachibus
was was das ganze auch sehr sehr unpredictable macht ne jetzt sind 30 leute um uns gesporn
klar den zweiten hätte ich jetzt noch killen können aber ich halte auch keine 30 leute
hier vorn ab zu spawnen kannst du kannst du vergessen
ok also was gibt es sonst noch lass mal überlegen ich also medic pistole und
pistole zum heilen und 100 prozent rätts es gibt einen typ der kann ein turret aufstellen
und hat so ein roboterhund dann hat man ein webster das ist der dude den ich hier spiele
mit dem grappling hook
den habe ich jetzt vergessen
an den sniper der sniper hat eine drohne
der sniper hat eine drohne und keine ahnung den spielt keiner
das sagt das ist eine sache die finde ich richtig gut an dem spiel sniper sagt
der raketenstaat nein wir haben es verpasst
na gut
ich hab schlepperes
komm mal hier
den roboter ach den roboterhund was hat denn boris dann noch mal
jetzt spornen gleich wieder pass auf 30 gegner auf einmal
was hat denn boris dann
den geschützturm ja hat er nicht noch hat er nicht noch was
ach ne stimmt es gibt nur ein primary gadget
ne dann kann ich ok ich hab nix gesagt
was
seriously
seriously der war nicht tot das war eine salve in kopf komplett
hat mir das gesehen
da sind keine bots es sind heute keine bots
das sind keine bots wenn es bots sind sieht man das
das sind alles echte spieler ich hab ja heute in meinem video gesagt es gibt durchaus spieler
die sind schlechter als bots
da gibt ja es gibt bots das ist eigentlich mit mein größter kritikpunkt dass es bots
gibt da steht ein ai im namen dahinter
sporn alles um mich drum herum im kreis
das wird so ein halbes jahr später fertig game
ne ich glaube das wird mir eigentlich so nie richtig fertig game
ich vermute ich predicte jetzt mal was
guck mal jetzt liegen sie nebeneinander und rufen wir hilfe
oder pass auf
die captain poggers rettet uns jetzt gegen den heli
entgegen entgegen allem jawoll
und jetzt rette ich euch
den play leute wir brauchen noch mal poggers in chat für team play
ok das hat sich jetzt nicht gelohnt
doch das sind spieler die sind teilweise teilweise halt ein bisschen pepega im kopf
gibt bots wenn es bots sind
sieht man das am namen
die heißen irgendwie military mäßig die heißen dann zum beispiel keine ahnung
captain zemmel oder so
und haben ai in der klammer dahinter und ich glaube ich hab diese runde nicht ein bot
gesehen
spiel wird nicht fertig weil also
was wollte ich denn
sagen
ja ich bin ich predicte jetzt was bringt danke für die ganzen subs ich hab heute null übersicht
ich blicke heute überhaupt nicht durch
also ich predicte jetzt mal was zu dem game ich glaube das game kommt also wenn das auch
nur ansatzweise mit diesen fehlern launst
was ich da jetzt was ich da jetzt
sich abzeichnet ja
dann predicte ich mal folgendes dass das spiel einen ähnlichen lauf nehmen wird wie battle
field 5
das spiel kommt raus und es spiel ein paar leute und dann
drümpelten das ein bisschen vor sich hin sie versuchen auch ein bisschen was und dann
müssen sie sich eingestehen das wird nix
serious max einladen ja wenn nicht gehen wir noch mal raus
also sollte das wirklich ich hab dich entweitet
oh nee bist du noch reingekommen bist du noch reingekommen
ah du bist drin poc bist du real zazu
ah nee der wurde gekickt also das predicte ich mal für das game sollte es wirklich mit
diesen großen problemen die ich heute auch in meinem video by the way in meinem werbemarkt
von meinem video könnt ihr euch angucken
ähm gesagt habe dann vermute ich es wird ein ähnlichen laufenden wie battle field 5
kann man zusammen mit freunden spielen ja
das cute squad ist assembled
sag mal ist das hier so ein battle royale flugzeug oder was
ist kein battle royale flugzeug
das ist der captain poggers der uns hingeflogen hat
ich doch mal jetzt wo wir meine loadout ausrüsten
schreckt easy
ok und das vertikale gameplay ist hier auch am start also du musst permanent eigentlich
gucken dass nicht von oben irgendwas anstellt an
dich
ok da ist schon der erste
übrigens diesen punkt hier
hier dieser punkt das reicht mir überhaupt nicht um den als freund zu erkennen
meine güte es ist jetzt gut heli mensch lasst mich in ruhe
battle royale wird nie harmonisieren mit battle field
ach ich weiß gar nicht also ich habe jetzt von einigen gehört ich habe selbst nicht
gespielt
das firestorm im kern gar nicht schlecht war und
vieles von dem hatte was im endeffekt auch modern warfare dann so ganz gut gemacht hat
so mit dieser plattenmechanik und sonst was
aber es war halt pay payment
was ist denn hier oben los das ist doch nicht normal
ok squad squad ich komme zu euch
schau hier oben ab
da ist was moment das spotten hat funktioniert
wait a minute das spotten hat funktioniert ich glaube es nicht
nein nein du siehst mich nicht ich bin im busch du siehst mich nicht ich bin im busch
vom boomer gebashed mein beileid
instagram wieder dauernd ja das ist ja nicht schade drum
wenn es nach mir geht könnte facebook und instagram und whatsapp und es könnte alles
dauerndauen sein
außer twitter twitter ist das einzige social network was ich verwendet
was ich auch für ganz sinnvoll halte
oh oh da kommt was da kommt was hast du dir so gedacht
she baited she baited
ja das gleiche twitter und reddit korrekt reddit ist gut
reddit ist gut oh ich hab ich hab released leute ich bin ppega
ppega ich bin jetzt richtig ppega
richtig massive ppega
hallo ich will zu meinem team excellent excellent so webster hookstalls
achtung auf gehts aufs dach
social media komplett schmutz na twitter mag ich twitter mag ich twitter ist
pock was verwendet ihr so seid ihr komplett abs wie heißt
es absent auf social media ist da heute keiner mehr
twitter ich verwende twitter twitter finde ich gut twitter twitter macht
auch irgendwie spaß und direkt mit den leuten da rumstülsen aber
was auf twitter nicht also eine sache die mich auf twitter halt richtig nervt ist diese
ganze ha wieso was denn
diese diese ich empöre mich über alles
blase die ist halt richtig hart auf twitter
ist er down ist er down oder nicht
nein ich nee darum ist was
cancel culture auf twitter ich mein ja ein bisschen vielleicht
ich meine aber hauptsächlich die die heute auf das aufspringen morgen auf das einfach
um sich empören zu können das ist das ist ppega richtig auf twitter
hier ist nix leute wir haben es wir haben es gecaptured und hier ist nix
wir müssen jetzt irgendwie zum nächsten punkt also fünf kilometer rennen man könnte vielleicht
wenn man glück hätte ein autotrocknen das klappt nicht das ist verbackt mit dem autotrocknen
du benutzt schüler vz willkommen in 2005 reicht das überhaupt war 2005 schüler vz überhaupt
noch ein ding
let earth bubble nee nee nee also flat earth ist out also ich muss wisst ihr was meine
ich hab schon öfters im stream gesagt aber heute sind ja ein bisschen andere leute aber
wisst ihr was meine mit abstand lieblingsverschwörungstheorie ist die ist nicht so bekannt aber die finde
ich das ist einfach die beste
meine lieblingsverschwörungstheorie ist obamas exenmensch bodyguard es gibt es gibt einfach
keine bessere hau hau hau hau lass mich lass mich
obamas exenmensch bodyguard leute
kann man sich hierwegs bewegen what the hell leute ich kann nicht zu euch die bashen mich
wenn ich zu euch komm alter
ok ich hab mich letztens drüber beschwert dass heli und crown infanterie gameplay zu
wenig interagieren jetzt habe ich das gegenteil hier die helis nerven
wenn wir jetzt ja richtig schön schnell retten können wisst ihr wie was ich machen würde
in battle field 3
in battle field 3 würde ich dv drücken und dann plopp
auf einmal sind sie alle wieder da ganz einfach und easy
easy af
pass mal auf poggers play poggers play incoming poggers play incoming
lass mich poggers plays machen nicht einfach von hinten wegstelzen
vor allem immer von hinten auch noch so richtig gachi bass in the ass man
also was ich vor hatte ist durchs dach auf diese kleine auf diesen kleinen vorsprung
zu hüpfen
da ist gerade was aufgeschlagen und das wäre ein richtiger six head move gewesen
komm wir gehen
die schützer alter die schützer
die packen lasst mich los lasst mich in ruhe da unten lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in
ruhe
da unten lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in ruhe
lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich in ruhe
Nächstes Magazin, nice GG Eats, warum habe ich jetzt sowas auf, habe ich das wirklich gerade drauf gemacht?
Reds, Teamplay, Vorgast, Vorgast, Teamplay, Anti-Tank Zeug, du kannst den Raketenwerfer mit
allem ausrüsten. Raketenwerfer kannst du mit allem ausrüsten, macht nur keiner, weil Medipack OP ist.
Cool, Rush of Grand Bazaar war Poggers ja, soll ich euch mal was sagen, Rush of Orbital wäre nicht
Poggers, Rush of Orbital wäre glaube ich noch schlimmer als das hier jetzt. Gut da oben sind
sie am Start. Poggers Squad, wo wollen wir hin? Rüber oder wo wollen wir hin? Rakete. Alles klar
Instant Death. Battlefield 1 hatte es auch noch gut, Battlefield 1 Rush mochte ich nicht. Ihr müsst mich
nicht resten, ich komme zu euch, das hat keinen Sinn. Nichts gegenüber Damavent Peak, Damavent Peak war
richtig Pog. Damavent Peak war massivster Pog, gab kaum mehr Pog als Damavent Peak,
weil übrigens wer es heute auf Twitter nicht gesehen hat, was lustig fand, mein Chef hat mich
heute angeschrieben, hat gemeint hier ich bin noch 22 Stunden im Minus mit der Zeiterfassung und
danach meinte er so und fürs die Battlefield Beta. Richtig geil, da sieht man mal 2021 ist das
ist das kein Ding, da spielt auch der da spielt auch der Chef die Battlefield Beta. Okay jetzt
spawnen hier 50.000 Gegner. Guck da sind schon die ersten. Du weißt halt nicht wo die spawnen,
das ist wirklich dumm, du hast keine Ahnung wo die spawnen. Hier, da, da spawn einer und nicht
nur hier, du hast wirklich keinen Plan wo die spawnen. Das verwirrt mich auch ziemlich, du kannst
es halt nicht kontrollieren. Hier unten ist nichts, ich werde erstmal snipen. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube da spielt also
wenn ich wenn ich das bei ihm richtig einschätze, glaube ich das spiele auf der Playstation. Leute
wollen wir die Rakete, wollen wir die Rakete erstelzen oder wollen wir lieber rüber zu C und A,
ich würde sagen kommen wir erstelzen die Rakete. Massive Raketenstelze. Die schießen uns ab,
wenn wir auf die Rakete fliegen, aber wir können es ja mal probieren. Da oben, guckt euch an die
kleinen Stelzes. Oh da unten, wir müssen runter Leute, die sind komplett unter uns, rechts ist einer.
Nice.
Rechts ist was.
Ich kann euch nicht ratzen. What? Alter man ist so brutal schnell dead man. Wurde ich gerätzt gerade?
Ne oder? Doch. Horrorskratz.
Wir müssen in das Auto Leute, wir müssen in das Auto, pass mal auf. Six head move, Six head move.
Nein, Six head move outplayed. Wir müssen in das Auto, wir müssen in das Auto. Und jetzt rein, rein
und ans Geschütz, äh, ans Geschütz. Ok, nächster Six head move. Wir fahren mit dem Auto hoch und
machen mit dem Geschütz alles weg. Da ist einer. Geschütz, hier Geschütz. Bashen, Bashen, Bashen.
Massive Bash Geschütz. Jawoll. Exquisite, exquisite. So, wir fahren jetzt auf den Vorplatz und das
Geschütz, das Geschütz basht bitte den Vorplatz. Ok, easy. Serious Max, ich ratze nicht. Ne, du
bist schon doof. Wow, Aua. Oh, da hat mich raus geschossen. Richtiges Pokplay, oder? Teamplay,
Teamplay ist immer noch King hier. Und schon haben wir es eingenommen oder fast zumindest.
Achtung, Six head time. Ah, da stellt sich schon einer von hinten ran. Der macht's richtig.
Guck, der Captain Poggers. Oh nein, Captain Poggers ist down. Captain Poggers, Captain Poggers. Ich
hole dich, ich hole dich. Huge Pok. Jawoll. Sag ich Leute, Teamplay. Kann man einschätzen,
wie die Nades fliegen. Die Animation ist viel zu schnell, finde ich. Und die Granaten danach zu
langsam. Passt irgendwie nicht richtig zusammen. Max, ich hole dich. Nein, ist schon dead.
Da ist was. Was ist hier? Was ist hier? Was ist hier? Nein, ich kack noob. Ich dachte,
da dreht sich schon nicht um. Wisst ihr, wenn man damit rechnet, dass die Gegner zu blöde sind,
dann ist auch nicht gut. Das ist dann auch blöd. Ich dachte, der kann mich nicht sehen. Moment,
Stripes, ich hole dich. Oh nee, da sind 50 Milliarden Gegner vor uns. Rechts. Nade spam.
Alter, die Nade. Habt ihr das gesehen? Ich hab die gekillt mit der Granate. Einfach
huge prediction. Nein, nein, nein. Bewegt dich. Die Rakete. Jetzt geht's ab. Guckt's euch an.
Captain Kirk auf dem Weg zum Mond. Ich hab in den Nachrichten gehört, der fliegt zu ISS oder so,
nicht zum Mond. Wie heißt der noch mal? Wie heißt der Kerl noch mal, der Captain Kirk gespielt hat?
Keine Ahnung. Der ist irgendwie 90 und fliegt zu ISS, hab ich in die News gelesen. Elon,
mach's Quatsch. Der Chat wieder, Mann. Ganz bestimmt Elon Musk, logisch. Shatner? Kann sein, ja.
William Shatner, genau. Jetzt. Ich war kein großer Star Trek Gucker, gestehen. Baumgart.
Shatner, genau. Chat ist wieder richtig kreativ heute. So, wo ist mein Team? Der eine ist da,
der andere ist da und einer ist bei mir gespawnt. Okay, lass mal zu Stripes, oder? Der ist am
sinnvollsten position. Ich warte jetzt einfach, ich geh jetzt zu Stripes rüber. Der will hier
C-Secure oder was das ist, man erkennt es nicht so genau bei der Brightness. Was ist mit den
Gegnern los? Wir haben sie übelst dominiert und jetzt das? Okay, Stripes springt gleich da. Aber
diesmal sieht man, das Game funktioniert halt einfach ohne Bots besser. Es ist so demotivierend,
Bots zu killen. Die Flaggensymbole sind unläsbar, ja. Vor allem jetzt, jetzt splitten die sich auch
noch auf. Stripes, die spawnen gleich 50 Leute um dich drum herum, weil das immer so ist. Nichts
los und dann Clusterfuck. Ich weiß nicht, wer die Maps bzw. diese Logik da oder sich gedacht hat,
es ist ein guter Spielfluss. Okay, guck da stellen sie sich schon. Da drüben sind sie schon am Start.
Da müssen wir jetzt hin. Moment, irgendwo da. Der hat eine Platte 100 pro, der hat so viel
ausgehalten. Midi-Pack, danke. Das war jetzt zu obvious, dass du um die Ecke kommst. Okay. Da
sind 50 Billionen auf der Gasse. Da sind by the way alles keine Bots, möchte ich mal drauf hinweisen.
Bots erkennt man im Namen. Oh Mist. Unten ist einer. Nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Hinter mir. Fuck, ich hab's. Oh ne, das war doch nicht mal der. Und warum released man die beste
Map in der Beta? Naja, weil der Rest schon nicht gut ist. Und wenn man dann noch eine der schlechten
Maps released, dann ist ja die Kritik ganz vernichtend. Deswegen vermute ich mal, dass
es deswegen ist. Was ist da oben los? Oh ne. Nein, ich will mal ein grappling hook. Da kommt was, Achtung, da kommt was. Da kommt noch mehr,
recht. Fuck, Alter, wie viele sind hier am Start? 50 Trillionen Gegner. Ey, vergiss es. 64 Spieler ist
einfach mind blown, Alter. Was willst du denn machen? Komm mal, wir killen die schon links und rechts,
aber du kannst einfach nichts machen. Was willst du tun? Okay, PP-Guard, rechts PP-Guard. Okay, die sind
durchgeflogen. Also die Letzten sind einfach durchgeflogen. Mensch. Keine 128, ich meine 64 Gegner. Es sind
128, 64 gegen 64. Das Game ist noch mega schlecht optimiert. Auch eigentlich geht's. Es geht, es ist
aber halt nicht so weich, wie es sein könnte. Es ist schon spielbar, aber es ist halt nicht, nicht
gut spielbar. Ja, es ist schlecht optimiert, du hast recht. Da wollte ich nicht hin.
Ja, X, EG Eats. Gibt's nicht. Okay, hier muss ich runter. Hier kommt nämlich garantiert gleich jemand hoch und er darf nicht wissen, wo ich bin. Deswegen gehe ich jetzt zum
Aufgang von der Flag und bash alle, die hochkommen. Eats, Next. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wo es ist.
Irgendwo da, ich werfe da einfach mal ein paar Nades hin. War das hier oben? Moment, die Nate hat
gehittert? Die Nate hat gehittert. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Easy, easy. Next. Oh, jetzt kommen viele hoch.
Jetzt kommen viele hoch. Ich hab's gesehen auch. Come on, Next. Oh, hier wird's voll, hier wird's voll, hier wird's voll.
Next. Das sind übrigens keine Bots, auch wenn die sich teilweise ein bisschen so anstellen.
No Bots. No Kappa. Kein Kappa. Kein Kappa, kein Kappa. Sagen wir mal, haben die unendlich Ladung hier?
Nein. Nein. Nochmal kurz Posy wechseln. Kurz Posy wechseln. Shit. Die kannst du so stellzen, ne?
By the way, Redhot, Redhot, Beste. Ich hör da unter mir, unter mir stellst. Man hört nicht viel,
man hört nicht viel, aber das hört man. Was war das für ein Dude mit seiner Magnavala?
Wo ist die Hexe, wenn man ihn braucht? Ja, die Hexe müsste ich mal entweiten, dann ist hier
stellste Lüx angesagt. Komm, wie viele haben wir jetzt gekillt? Acht Stück oder so? Oh nein,
da unten war einer vom Team. Nope, nope, nope, Leute, lasst mich spawnen bei euch. Direkt weg,
direkt weg stellzen. Pogger spawnen. Pog spawnen. Da will er mich doch tatsächlich mit der Rakete
stellzen, ich glaub's nicht. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Durf, so nicht. So nicht. Seht ihr auch,
wie schnell das Helz-Rack einsetzt? Ich hab keinen Mini-Pack oder so genommen. Das Rack
einfach instant. Jetzt hab ich einen Mini-Pack, jetzt bin ich voll. Okay, ich wollte was probieren,
hat nicht so wirklich gut funktioniert. Ich komm runter, Leute. Team, ich komme, ich eile.
Fuck, den hab ich nicht gesehen. Wusste nicht, dass der da am Start ist. Shit, hab ich das nicht mit
gerechnet. So, sind das Friendlies? Wahrscheinlich sind es keine Friendlies. Wahrscheinlich sind es
20 Gegner. Ihr seht die Leiste nicht? Welche Leiste seht ihr nicht? Was, wie, was? Der Fabian,
der Fabian, der spielt komische Weep-Games. Ja, ja, ja. Me weep, me spam, mod backer if ban.
Macht der jetzt? Mensch, du bist ja immer noch da. Ah, Eats, Victory, easy. Eats, easy. Ihr wisst,
umso knapper es ist, ist es immer, also, die Skala ist so, ist es wirklich easy,
dann muss man nichts sagen. Ist es knapp. Und umso knapper es ist, umso mehr ist es easy. Versteht
ihr was ich meine? Also easy ist genau umgedreht, wie sagt man, umgedreht proportional zur reellen
easiness. True, ja, ist so. Hier sogar so weit gehen sagen, true 0w. By the way, wir haben easy
anti-cheat sogar, wenn das nicht schon was heißt. Lad, äh, renax ein. Hab ich dich im, hab ich dich
im in origin, wenn ich schicke mal eine Anfrage oder sag mal wie du heißt. Du hast keine Anfrage
geschickt. Wie heißt du denn? So wie hier? Hab ich nicht bekommen. Ah, ja, ich hab dich. Okay,
oh Mist, jetzt sind wir schon im Game. Aber ich hab dich in weitet. Kann man social, kann man hier,
Sekunde, kann man hier Leute jetzt noch einladen? Geht das, geht das während der Runde? X more,
was X? Squad und players? Ja, entscheidend. Hat jemand einen Plan, ob man während der Runde
in weitet kann? Rechts ist Social. Ah, okay, hast was gekriegt. Müsste, müsste, müsste,
müsste es was bekommen haben. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt. Sack, das, das, das, alles klar. Ja, das UI
ist schon noch bisschen Pains, Pains Champ. Seht ihr die Range des Grappling Hooks? Habt ihr's gehört?
Der hat Ayaya Intensifies laufen im Auto. Ich hab's genau gehört. Ich bin drauf, easy, auf geht's.
Okay, wenigstens geht das noch. Wenigstens, wenigstens, wenigstens funktioniert das noch.
Man kann auf dem Auto obendrauf stehen und mitfahren. Das Game möchte nicht, dass ich so was mache.
Dabei wäre der Play eigentlich relativ sixhead gewesen, vom Auto mich da draufstelzen. Leute,
ich bin nicht an den Gegnern gestorben, ich hab mich durch die Wand gehuckt wieder.
Okay, wo geht hier was? Dreck, next. Wo ist hier was?
Minigun. Ich dachte, ich krieg den Typ aus dem Auto down. Aber mein Squad ist strong, easy.
Zack, sind wir wieder da. Gut programmiert, Collision Detection ist eh komplett overrated.
Brauchen wir nicht. Ich meine ernsthaft, wozu? Wozu Collision Detection? Man sollte prinzipiell
Noclip machen für alle. Ja, Kollege. Nein, du sollst mich nicht snipen. Easy nade, easy
nade, easy life. Wo gehen wir jetzt hin? Wo ist hier was? Da, da ist auch was. Der Schneibermann.
Wäre auch scheiße gewesen, wenn ich das kontesten könnte gegen den Sniper, oder? Wobei ich
dann auch wieder hätten wetten können. Eigentlich war ich drauf. Wie schaut es mit Microtransactions
aus? Nichts. Nichts. Bis jetzt. Not good. Not good. Komrade. Not good, Co-Komrade. Oh,
wir spawnen auf dem Dach. Massive position. Kannst du mal? Pass auf, Poggasnade, Poggasnade,
Poggasnade. Okay, die waren zu weit. Sag mal, what the hell? Okay, die haben echt keinen
Bock zu sterben gerade. Na jetzt aber. General Patrick. By the way, kein Bot, auch wenn der
Name ähnlich ist. Wo ist hier was? Bleibst du hier? Hier geblieben. Nades. Fuck. Den
verfolgen wir jetzt. Okay, geht nicht. Übrigens, habt ihr die Zerstörung gesehen? Mehr Zerstörung
gibt's in dem Spiel nicht. Das war's. That's all. Also wer sich jetzt fragt, was hier bezüglich
Revolution und Zerstörung und so ist, das ist alles. Ich blicke nicht mehr durch, das wird
zu viel gerade. Wo mein Hirn überfordert. Zumal guckt mal auf die Uhr. Wisst ihr, was
mein Hirn auch noch überfordert? Bald ist Betge. Und kurz vor Betge kann man eigentlich
keine großartige Bastion mehr machen. Betge und Bastion beißt sich, das geht nicht zusammen.
War da was? Nee. Wo ist mein Team da? Perfekt. Easy. Wo geht man hin? Aufs Dach? Wollen
wir mal aufs Hochhaus? Leute, komm, wir gehen aufs Hochhaus. Hintenrum, hintenrum an der
Zip-Line rauf. Würde ich sagen. Gibt's hier neben ein? Ich auch eine Zip-Line. Und was
ich mich auch noch frage ist, ist man so schneller? Was? Ich hab nichts gemacht übrigens. Das
ist einfach so runtergehüpft. Schlafen kann man noch genug, wenn man tot ist. Ja, nee.
Boah, mein Schlaf. Oh, da oben ist ganz schön viel los. Direkt hier oben ist einer. What
the fuck, man? Das ist aber Battlefield. So magisch das. Achtung, da ist einer hoch.
Den stellsten wir jetzt. Nein, Pistol. Fuck, ich dachte nicht, dass die links gelaufen
ist. Starke Sprunggelenke der eine Gegner da. Ja, mit Physik nehmen sie es hier eh nicht
so eng. Okay, wir sind alle da. Aber ich glaube, wir haben ganz gut was weggebasht, sodass
wir hier oben vielleicht Fuß fassen konnten. Jo, wir haben es. Nice. Ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, wo die sind. Wo ist hier was? Herr Poggers, ich retz dich. Sind da noch Gegner?
Unter uns ist glaube ich noch einer. Null. Man bekommt es in grün angezeigt. War da was?
Man bekommt es in grün angezeigt, wenn er den Rätsel annimmt oder wie? Das war mir neu.
Da fühlt man sich alleine. Ja, das ist doch alles so groß und so pixelzählerig hier.
Wo haben wir denn jetzt hier was? D ist das auf einmal mitten auf dem Feld. Da unten
ist ein Heli-Stellungsamt stand. Wann ist denn D? Normalerweise auf dem Feld ist doch
gar nichts. Es verwirrt mich hoch gar nicht manchmal das Game. Wo gehen wir denn hin?
Ich gehe mit dem Serious Max hinterher. Er will bestimmt zur Rakete, so wie ich den kenne.
Ne, der will zur D2. Oh nein. Leute, ich hätte vier Stück. Bam, bababam. No, I don't speak
Dutch. Only speak German. And French. Poor girls. Lass mich spawnen please. Latein, ja.
Ah. Wallbang, wallbang. Nice. Oh Mist. Ich hätte so. Na gut, es ist drei Gegner, die
mich ab aimen. Was willst du machen? Dein French raus. Aber die Wallbang-Nade war schon
nice. Aber ich muss dazugeben. Alter, was ist denn jetzt los gerade? Da headshotte er
mich mit der Magnum von oben. Granaten werfen, das stimmt. Leider haben sie ein bisschen,
ja, das macht Bock. Es müsste noch ein bisschen mehr Animation und Wurfprojektiv und so,
das ein bisschen zusammenpassen. Oh ne, das war ver-aimt. Okay, da wusste ich jetzt nicht,
was ich machen soll, weil mein Hook nicht da war. Gibt's Crossplay? Jep, gibt es. Okay,
die Runde ist tatsächlich schwieriger als der Rest. Davor einfach easy as fuck durch
und jetzt doch relativ anspruchsvolle Gegner. Auf geht's hier. Yolo. Es kann aber auch sein,
dass mein Buma-Gehirn müde wird. Ich tippe drauf. Ich tippe, mein Buma-Gehirn wird müde.
Wir haben Sturm. Please, kann ich noch einmal von vorne oder irgendwas, was ich sehe, sterben?
SPMM knallt langsam. Ich hatte zwischendrin immer mal so Runden. Ich hatte zwischendrin
immer mal so Runden, wo dann die Gegner halt auch ein bisschen gedrückt haben und so. Man
kann nicht jede Runde 40 plus haben, wobei wir erstaunlich viele Runden 30, 35, 40 plus
haben. Was ist hier los? Ein Dog. Okay, wie soll das genau hier funktionieren? Achtung,
schnellstrennen, rennen, rennen, rennen. Nein. Nein. Alter, du sollst doch nicht hier nicht
drüber, Mann. Nein, nein, wir gehen ins Auto. Hier ist ein Auto mit LMG-Legit.
Okay. What the?
In das Sack habe ich ihn geschultet. Richtig ins Sack geschossen gerade. Ist er dahinter?
Ich glaube, das ist er. Das ist er. Wo ist hier was? Nix da? BP-Gas. Okay, es spawnen
jetzt hier gleich ganz viel. Ich muss da unbedingt hoch. Hier spawnen. Sobald du hier
captcha spawnen sie. Erstmal kastrieren, genau. Schnipp, schnapp. Wo spawnen sie rein hier?
Jetzt können sie nicht mehr rein spawnen. Bleibst du oben? Hier spawnen keine rein.
Alter, ich habe Space. Nope, kein Space. Wurde ich gerade geretzt? Ich wurde gerade geretzt.
Sorry Leute, das war, hat es total überschnitten. Hä? Was ist hier los? Da ist was. Nein, was,
was ist hier? Fuck. Max, ich hole dich. Da kommt jetzt gleich einer rauf. Achtung. Hier
kommt gleich einer rauf, der bestens. Oder auch nicht. Ich komme mir fast vor wie ein
Overwatch-Winner-Maker hier mit diesen komischen Enterhaken-Jumps. Jetzt, ja jetzt ist das
auch ein Nice hier. Da kommt ein Auto. LMG-Legit. Ich dachte unter mir ist er. Nope. Sind die
oben irgendwo? Oh, jetzt wird es mehr hier. Oh, mein Crabling ist noch nicht da. Ich habe
das Timing noch nicht so hundertprozentig drauf. Ich bilde mir auch einen, den haben
die ein bisschen slower gemacht im Vergleich zu gestern. Oder, oder ich schätze es komplett
falsch ein. Soll ich mal sagen, dass die Wettereffekte wirklich cool sind, wenn die so selten kommen
wie jetzt. Wir hatten jetzt fast den ganzen Abend halt gutes, gutes Wetter. Rakete! Leute,
guckt es euch an. Haha, guck mal. Wait a minute. Ich glaube so ist das nicht gedacht. Oh, da
kommt was. Achtung. Ich glaube so ist das nicht gedacht. Ich sehe nichts. Wir naden einfach
mal in die Ecke. Ich habe ihn gehittet mit der Granate. Einfach blinde Granate. Okay,
so nicht. Ach, man kann es ja mal probieren. Oh ne, oh ne, mein Aim. Pepega-Aim. Leute,
ich kann euch nicht retzen. Ich weiß nicht, wo der Gegner hin ist. Glaub doch, ich glaube
jetzt geht es. Ich glaube jetzt geht es. Ich komme runter. Porgas. Porgas, ich retze dich.
Der wollte dich looten gerade, die Sau. Erinnere mich an Shanghai Tower ein bisschen, aber
ich finde es besser. Also Shanghai war ja wirklich langweilig. Da war einfach alles
weiß auf der Map danach. Irgendwo hier ist doch was. Oh, das hat er gut gemacht. Dachte
ich kann das, aber gut. Für irgendwas muss ein Sniper gut sein. Oh Reds, jawoll. Pass
auf, da schneidert es noch irgendwo. Genau ein Basier, das machst du bei dir, direkt
vor dir. Da irgendwo. Der lebt nicht mehr, oder? Schreckt. Den haben wir gut outplayed,
oder? Lass mich in Ruhe. Das ist ein Bot. Das war ein Bot gerade, den wir outplayed haben.
Habt ihr am Namen gesehen, oder? Guckt. Bot. Alles Bots. Das sind jetzt Bots. Ich versuche
euch zu holen, Leute. Könnt ihr runterkrabbeln, das geht nicht, ne? Oh, da ist ja noch was.
Fuck. Ja klar. Aber im Squad muss ich sagen, macht das Spiel tatsächlich noch mehr Spaß.
Es macht mir auch so schon Bock, bis auf die riesen Probleme, die ich angesprochen habe
in meinem Video heute. Aber es macht noch mehr Bock. Aber die Sache ist halt die, ich glaube
langfristig, also wenn das wirklich die Probleme am Schluss hat, die ich so mal predicted
habe, auch aus dem Video heute. Was geht hier eigentlich gerade? Der Sturm, Leute. Monka.
Sturm. Wollen wir mal fliegen gehen? Wir gehen mal fliegen. Passt mal auf, Leute, wir
gehen fliegen. Nein. Lass mich in Ruhe. Achtung. Auf geht's.
Fliegestellts. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Monka S. Hat schon was, oder? Ich glaube
übrigens, dass der Dreck, den er aufpickt, nicht wirkliche Physikobjekte irgendwie aus
der Map sind, sondern randomized einfach beim Tornado rumstellst. Guck mal, wie hoch man
da fliegen kann. Da fliegt ein Kühlschrank. Hier fliegt ein Kühlschrank rum. Ey, da schießt
auf mich. Anzeige ist raus. Wow. Ich habe ein Auto gegen das Gesicht gekriegt. So hoch
wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das hat mich aus der Map gekickt.
Das hat mich aus der Map gekickt. So, wirklich großartige Auswirkungen. Ansonsten hat der
Sturm da nicht. Was, wenn man hier sich auf den anderen Teil in der Map aufgehalten hätte?
So. Falsch. Respawn Timer. Respawn. Guck mal, wie OP das ist. Ich bin hinter den Gegnern
gespawnen. Der weiß nicht, dass ich da bin. Instant direkt. Von wo, Mensch? Packt, das
war dumm. Das ist ein Bot, der da auf mich schießt. Da außen kommt was gerade. Midi-Pack,
gegen Midi-Pack. Sixthand. Damit hat er nicht gerechnet. Der denkt, ich gehe links, jetzt
gehe ich doch rechts. Outplayed, outplayed. Jawoll, so mag ich das. Ich wusste, dass du
kommst. Okay, mehr geht nicht. Mehr geht nicht. Also mehr ohne Midi-Pack kannst du nicht machen.
Ich erinnere noch mal dran. 37-jähriger Boomer hier am spielen. Gib ihm hart. Mehr ging leider
nicht. So, wo gehen wir jetzt hin? Hier ist mein Team. D1. Alter, unter mir. Was ist denn
hier los? Oh Mist. Aber Pogger-Snakes wieder. Sixthand-Nades.
Alter Webster, du machst mir Angst, wenn du mich so anguckst. So, Leute. Ah, da seid
ihr. Ja, die Runde machen wir auf jeden Fall noch fertig. Trotz Boomer-Badgetime. Nein.
Ich hätte mich lieber ran hucken sollen an die Kisten. Die Map, also gerade so an diesen
Stellen wirkt die Map halt einfach random generiertes Terror und dann Assets aus dem
Level-Editor einfach verteilt. Easy. Easy. Easy. Fertig. Map. Moin. L-R-S. Pff. Fehler.
Jetzt müssen wir aber mal hier mal in uns. Guck mal, die Gegner haben voll aufgeholt.
Es liegt daran, dass wir kein 40-Kill-Gameplay getroppt haben. Jaja, lass mich in Ruhe.
Geh weg. Nice. Bin ich ganz sicher, wie ich hier jetzt ran komme. Mann, von jede Ecke
respawn hier einer und stellst da rum, Mann. Du kommst überhaupt nicht, kommst überhaupt
nicht vorwärts, Mensch. Vorsichtiger kann ich doch gar nicht mehr vorwärts stellzen.
Geht doch nicht. Unmöglich. Da geh ich jetzt nicht hin, ihr müsst in den Hotspot rein und
in your face. Das muss klatschen, Alter. Mach mal Abonnenten-Squad, hab ich doch. Aber
ich spiel letzte Runde jetzt. Last Round. Heute sind die Heli schon besser als gestern.
Das ist cute, cute, cute-Squad ist am Start. Mann, kann ich noch irgendwas, irgendwas schießen,
ohne von irgendwo anders instant zu hittet werden, Alter. Das ist ja grad ganz schlimm.
Geht ja gar nichts. Ziel ist ja auf den Gegner. Direkt weggefurzt.
Okay, hier unten vermutet einen niemals jemand. Hier ist nämlich normalerweise auch keiner.
Wir können jetzt hier gleich 5, 5, hoch hucken. Da ist ja keiner mehr da. Sind hier alle down.
Mann, sag mal. Ich werd immer von der Seite instant hittet gerade. Komm, schieß auf den
Gegner. Wieder weggefurzt, Mann. Was ist das? Was soll ich denn noch machen? Oh, sieben,
wir sind down, wir sind down. Wir haben, yep. Danke, Ds, Jungs. Nö, ich auch. Easy, easy
loss. Setke, Betke. Mal gucken. Ich guck nochmal schnell in den Chat rein. Irgendwas
mal sehen, ob... Weil ich gestern bei TC Bounty im Chat ein bisschen wuppimouts gespammt hab.
Ich hoffe, er hat sich gefreut über den Haust. Komm, heute hausten wir ein paar Videos wieder
mal. In diesem Video, nur in diesem Stream, nur ganz kurz. Warum Battlefield 22? Ja gut,
der macht ja keinen Gaming-Content. Komm schon, Alter, ist nicht so spät. Für mich ist
das viel. Ich bin jetzt dreieinhalb Stunden on. Das kann ich immer im Alter nicht mehr.
Ja, es ist vorbei. Setke. Die Summa Jahre sind vorbei. Er spielt doch Arma 3, wirklich?
Wusste ich gar nicht. Wir raiden ihn. Wir raiden ihn mal. Raids ein paar Videos. Eats.
Wie, es gibt plus 250 Kekse? Nice. Also, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz. Wir sehen uns
dann wahrscheinlich morgen beim nächsten Stream. Und, jo. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.